Das war's für heute.
Woop Arrive ist weg?
Warum ist Woop Arrive weg?
Weird Champ.
Woop Leaf ist noch da.
Guck Woop Leaf ist noch da.
Vielleicht soll ich das als Subscriber Emotes rein machen, dann können sie nicht weggehen.
Gibt es kein Woop Arrive mehr?
Woop Arrive Emote?
Woop Arrive.
Nein.
Der Chainlord hat es glaube ich gelöscht.
Da müssen wir warten.
Bis er wieder am Start ist.
Er kann es mir einfach schicken, dann kann ich es hier als Sub Emote.
Ich habe glaube ich noch 4 Emotes offen als GIF Emote.
Naja gut.
So Big Stonks heute.
Wir gucken mal was es so gibt.
Ich brauche ein paar Sachen.
Schauen wir mal ob es irgendwelche gescheiten Deals gibt.
Kennt jemand gute Deal Übersicht Seiten?
Wo man nicht nur gebadet wird.
Ich habe früher ganz gerne hier China Gadgets geguckt.
Allerdings sind die mir auch ziemlich Sellout mäßig geworden.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe immer der gleiche Kram und nicht so super spannend.
Hier Questions.
Kennst du ein gutes kostenfreies Nugget Package?
Oh nee.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen habe ich noch nie gemacht.
PDFs generiert.
Ich habe bei Excel generiert.
Aber da gibt es offizielle Sachen von Microsoft zum Excel.
Leute ich wünsche es keinem Excel generieren zu müssen.
Auf Amazon nur Schrott My Deals.
Auf die wollte ich tatsächlich mal gucken.
Aber da war auch letztens nicht so viel dabei.
Was?
Schreck Socken?
Moment.
Nein oder?
Das hat mit Schreck gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist einfach nur im Bild hier.
Ich habe gedacht es gibt Schreck Socken.
Übrigens ist euch mal aufgefallen.
Mir ist das irgendwie zum ersten Mal.
Obwohl ich die Katze jetzt schon zwei Jahre habe.
Meine Katze sieht von den Farben her fast ein bisschen aus wie der gestiefelte Kater aus Schreck.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Naja.
Ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Guck mal mein Video wird empfohlen.
Oh Leute wir müssen gleich.
Ich muss gleich ich muss gleich was los werden.
Jetzt ich warte aber ich warte aber noch.
Weil ich wahrscheinlich mir vorstellen könnte dass es ein Thema ist was mehr Leute interessieren.
Ich habe ein paar Comments gelesen und zudem muss ich einfach mal was was los werden.
Und das ist glaube ich nichts was sich irgendwie für ein Video eignet.
Sondern wo ich wo ich einfach mal ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen labern muss drüber.
Machen wir machen wir dann aber später.
Wir haben nämlich ein paar wirklich coole Comments gefunden.
Ja einer hat sich zum Beispiel drüber aufgeregt.
Dass ich so schlimm bin wie Jens Spahn.
Kein Witz.
Das steht da wirklich.
Ich bin ich bin quasi in einer Linie zu sehen eben mit Jens Spahn.
Hat er geschrieben.
Kein Scherz jetzt.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau warum.
Aber okay.
Jeder jeder was er will.
Soll er schreiben.
Und einer hat auch geschrieben so dass da sicher wahrscheinlich nie Fehler eingestehen würde.
Und die Leute feiern das mega ab.
Und ich wollte einfach mal was dazu sagen.
Dass ich der Meinung bin das Content Creator.
Da gar nicht so unschuldig sind wie man denkt.
Allerdings.
Aus anderen Gründen wie man denkt.
So.
Aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal Big Stonks Deals.
Nachdem wir uns die Schrecksocken bestellt haben.
Ich wollte schon immer Schrecksocken haben.
So was haben wir sonst noch.
Black Week Deal.
Oh ne.
Sag mal hat jemand hat jemand zufällig von euch.
Aldi Talk.
Und hat sich heute morgen versucht.
Ein zu locken.
Dings wie heißt das bei denen hier.
Aldi Talk Kunden Kunden login oder so.
Das ging bei mir nicht.
Egal was ich probiert habe.
Ich konnte mich nicht einlocken.
Ich konnte nicht mal recovery machen.
Und nicht mal SMS recovery machen.
Das ging einfach nix.
Aldi Talk taugt das was ja für meine Mutter.
Ist das beispielsweise super.
Weil es.
Weil Prepaid drauf steht.
Aber es nicht wirklich.
Also.
Es hat mit dem klassischen Prepaid nichts zu tun.
Aber.
Die ist nicht so modern.
Also.
Wenn da Prepaid drauf steht.
Bei der fühlt sie sich gut.
Obwohl es ja eigentlich auch nicht wirklich Prepaid ist.
Du musst jeden Monat bezahlen.
Nur dass du es halt im Vorfeld aufladen musst.
Was aber eigentlich kein Unterschied ist.
Weil du willst ja nicht.
Dass es.
Dass es down geht.
So.
Und übrigens.
Was mich auch bei Aldi Talk.
Immer richtig krass an Scam erinnert.
Guck mal.
Aldi Talk.de.
Richtige Seite Zertifikat.
Alles da.
Und jetzt kommt es.
Wenn ihr bei Aldi Talk auf einen Long drückt.
Einen Long drückt.
Kommt man hier raus.
Aldi Talk Kundenbetreuung.de.
Da denke ich im ersten Moment.
Werd ich gerade gefischt.
Ich mein.
Warum.
Warum machen die das nicht.
Unter Aldi Talk.de.
Bitte schön.
Damit.
Pfeifert-Uhrl.
Nee.
Low-Brain-Uhrl.
Würde ich sagen.
Richtig.
Low-Brain-Uhrl.
Ja.
Richtig.
Low-Brain-Uhrl.
Ja.
Richtig.
Massive Gebate.
Alter.
Massive.
Massive Gebate.
Die Scheiße funktioniert.
Hier.
Das ist aber dumm.
Weil ich muss wieder aufladen.
Teste mal das Lidl Cloud.
Warte mal.
Was.
Ist es ein Scherz.
Hat Lidl Cloud Hosting.
Chat.
Ist das.
Ist das so.
Oder werde ich gebated.
Ich halte heute aber sowas alles für möglich.
Lidl.
Okay.
Warte.
Lidl.
Cloud.
Hosting.
Nicht.
Stack it.
Okay.
Das hat ja mit Lidl jetzt nichts zu tun oder.
Was.
Was ist da an Lidl.
Partner.
Bei Partner steht wahrscheinlich Lidl drunter.
Ist das das hier.
Co-Location.
Leistung.
Oster-Meeting.
Campos Daily Scrums.
Cloud.
Produkte und Services.
Ach.
Den gehört Lidl.
Oder was.
Oder.
Ja.
Wusste ich nicht.
Ähm.
Produkte nachmaß.
Loadba.
Heieiei.
Jetzt wird es aber.
Das aber sportliche Loadbalancer ab 22 Euro.
Bei Hetzner geht das glaube ich bei 3,50 Euro los.
Übrigens.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Hetzner sind.
Wenn ihr auf der Suche nach einem nice Cloud-Anbieter seid für eure Projekte.
Schaut doch mal Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat.
Schaut mal bei Hetzner vorbei.
Günstige Geschichten.
Und ich bin persönlich super zufrieden mit der ganzen Sache.
Ich hab da auch einige Sachen von mir schon seit Jahren laufen.
So.
Pricing.
Prices.
Hier.
Loadbalancer.
Ah.
Die haben hier keine Loadbalancer Prices drinstehen.
Okay.
Aber das kostet nicht.
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Object Storage.
Hosted MongoDB ab 108.
Also die langen aber schon gut zu hier die Jungs von Lidl.
Muss man mal sagen.
Läuft der auch mal Minecraft.
Klar.
Easy läuft der da drauf.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Ihr macht das nächstes Jahr bei Hetzner.
Ihr könnt ja mal ein Startgutscheincode nehmen.
Was wahrscheinlich bei euren 10.000 Ausgaben nicht viel macht.
Ich hab das übrigens mal lustiger gemacht.
Ich hab das mal auf der Arbeit vorgeschlagen.
Wir hatten ja so Probleme mit NFS Storage und Azure Files.
Und da waren wir auch so in einem Meeting und haben rum gesehen.
Ich hab gesagt, das ist kacke.
Das ist langsam.
Und die anderen meinten so, ja aber SSD kosten 70.000.
Kein Witz.
70.000 Euro SSD kosten im Monat.
Für SSDs bei Azure.
Und da hab ich so eingeworfen so nach dem Motto, was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn wir
zu einem anderen Cloud-Anbieter gehen?
Ich hätte dann Hetzner 20 Euro Startgutschein.
Und dann haben sie alle nur gemacht.
Hab ich gesagt, aber ich mein das ernst.
Warum gehen wir nicht wirklich zu einem anderen Anbieter?
Aber irgendwie haben sie alle nur gecakt.
Das war denen nicht Business Stonks genug.
Die wollen lieber 70.000 Euro Azure Cloud SSDs.
70.000 Euro SSD.
Ja, das ist teuer.
Azure Calculator.
Reißrechner.
Pass mal auf.
Das ist teuer.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wir da eingegeben haben.
So.
Auf Microsoft.
Ok.
Virtualer Computer Anzeigen.
Also dieser Rechner ist wirklich ein richtig krasser Paints-Champ.
So.
Managed Disks.
SSD Standard.
So.
Und wir brauchen hier...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel wir gebraucht haben.
Also wir haben mehrere dieser fetten Kisten, dieser fetten Disks gebraucht.
Und hier bist du...
Ich hab's mal damals im Stream erzählt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Guck mal, hier bist du schon ein paar monatliche Kosten für 5000 Euro.
Wobei, wir können auch ein kleineres Modul nehmen.
Wo ist denn der Krempel jetzt hier oben?
Ach nee, wir mussten ja die fette Kiste nehmen, dass man fette SSDs dranhauen kann.
Zumindest, das Ganze summiert sich dann.
Und dann kommst du auf ungefähr 70.000 Euro Kosten im Monat.
Im Monat.
Ja, also das ist wirklich richtig, richtig Paints-Champ.
Und das hat ihm nicht gefallen, ja.
Tatsächlich, tatsächlich, das ist richtig.
Vor allem bin ich der Ansicht, dass viele auch mit deutlich kleiner dimensionierten Sachen, oder...
Du kannst ja mal in den Chat schreiben, wie du das siehst.
Aber ich bin der Meinung, es kommen vielen auch mit deutlich...
Erstens einfacheren Sachen.
Und zweitens kleiner dimensionierten Sachen aus, als man eigentlich denkt.
Also man braucht, wenn man irgendwie zwei Web-Anwendungen laufen lassen will, nicht irgendwie den krassen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Und man braucht auch keine super krassen 64-Core-Kisten.
Da gibt es ja immer so ein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür, wo ich mal gemietet habe mit jemanden von, der sich um unsere externen Webseiten kümmert.
Wir haben ja über 800 externe Webseiten.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht so genau, wofür wir das haben, aber wir haben die, ja.
Und die haben gemeint, Max, da kommt eine richtig fette neue Seite.
Wo ist der Chainlow, wenn man Recycle-Stories braucht im Chat?
Aber der meint so, ja, es kommen richtig, richtig fette, richtig viele Anfragen.
Und da habe ich den damals so gefragt, ja, okay, was heißt das, mit wie viel Anfragen rechnen wir denn dann?
Und ich weiß die genaue Zahl nicht mehr, Leute.
Ich weiß die genaue Zahl nicht mehr.
Aber da kam dann irgendwie so was wie 1000 Anfragen.
Und da habe ich dann gesagt, oh, das ist aber ganz schön viel.
1000 in der Sekunde.
Und dann meinte er irgendwie so was wie, am Tag.
Und dann hat er so gesagt so, bäm, hat er das gesagt so nachdem und so, guck mal hier, krasse Seite, 1000 am Tag.
Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, na gut, wenn Raspberry Pi Zero ins W-Land irgendwo unter das Dach oder so.
Wird das wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren.
Aber der war richtig, der war richtig überzeugt davon.
Hat uns Dice wenigstens den Pre-Order-Bonus gegeben, hab damals gepre-ordert.
Was ist denn der Pre-Order-Bonus?
Irgendwie das Battlefield Knife, das Battlefield 3 Knife ist der Pre-Order-Bonus, oder?
Ihr könnt euch das jetzt aussuchen.
Wir können zwei Sachen machen.
Entweder wir gucken uns jetzt direkt Big Brain Black Friday Sales Angebote an.
Er ist Lionstar.
Danke für den Massive-Huge.
Und wenn ich mal ein Prime-Sub-Moment, das ist ja ein richtig echter.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, mir war es einfach so danach.
So, also wir können, ne, das dürft ihr in den Chat schreiben.
Ich mache dann so Pi mal Daumen.
Ja, richtiger Sub gibt noch mehr als einen IQ-Punkt.
Also, danke für deine Hilfe, Arbeit und Unterstützung.
Nice, ja schön, dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast.
Ich habe dich noch nie gesehen hier.
Richtig Pog.
Und wenn ich in die Historie küsse, du hast auch schon drei Nachrichten erst geschrieben.
Also du bist wirklich ziemlich neu am Start.
Max gefällt dir Halo Infinite und kommt vielleicht, ja, wahrscheinlich ist sogar das nächste Video Halo Infinite.
Ich muss sagen, mal ganz kurz zu Halo Infinite.
Es macht mir mega Bock.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst davor, weil SBMM kickt.
Weil Halo Infinite hat SBMM.
Danke Nils, FPS, Massive Prime Subscription.
Zwölf Monate, du hast jetzt als erstes den Goldkeks erreicht.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt, ja.
Kann ich dir, kann ich dir nicht helfen?
Das wüsste ich auch gerne.
Du hast auch den Goldkeks.
Richtig Pog, Leute, richtig Pog.
Also, ihr könnt, ihr könnt euch das jetzt aussuchen.
Und zwar entweder gucken wir uns jetzt Massive Deals an, weil ich will, ich will mir ja nicht vorwerfen lassen.
Ich würde meinen Chat mit dem Titel des Streams irgendwie gibben und dann was anderes erst mal eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde machen.
Also, aber ich glaube, das andere Thema interessiert euch auch.
Gerade die Leute, die auch ein bisschen hier das ganze Battlefield Drama auf YouTube mitbekommen haben.
Aber, also, entweder gucken wir uns jetzt Big Brain Stonks Deals an.
Big Brain Stonks Deals, das ist das richtige Zungenpray.
Sagt das mal schnell miteinander, Leute.
Big Brain Stonks Deals, Big Brain Stonks Deals.
Das ist wirklich sehr belastend für die Zunge.
Der Hetzener Code gibt sogar, gibt sogar 2380.
Das habe ich auch nicht genau verstanden, warum, ehrlich gesagt.
Vielleicht ist die eine Währungsumrechnung Geschichte.
Ich weiß nicht.
Aiaiai.
Oder besser gesagt.
Dankeschön, Linestar.
Wer hat gedodged?
Erst mal gucken, wer hat erfolgreich gedodged?
Okay, die Hälfte hat wieder erfolgreich gedodged.
Ich sehe es schon.
Obwohl, das sind ja alles Subs hier.
Also, wer kriegt denn hier was?
John Can Play.
Oh, Nusen.
Ballistix.
Bonbon.
Surdi.
Tas.
Lurio.
Rocky.
JS.
Der Rute vom Mond.
Chorios und Quadratskunde.
Pok.
Nee.
Quadrat.
Sekunde.
Nicht Quadratskunde.
Quadratsekunde.
Ja.
Sehr schön.
Nice.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen neuen Sub-Rekord-Stand, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich sage es aber nicht, weil vielleicht raten wir nachher noch eine Runde.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben einen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, wir haben einen neuen Sub-Rekord-Stand.
Das habe ich nämlich schon gestern gesehen, weil ich wieder mal neue Emote-Slots bekommen
habe.
Neue Emote-Slots, von denen ich mittlerweile, glaube ich, 9 habe und immer noch keine neuen
Slots am Start habe.
Aber wenn mein BigBrain-Stonks-Manager gerade im Chat ist, wir sollten uns mal um neue Emotes
kümmern.
Ich bin übrigens mittlerweile unter die richtigen Profi-Content-Creators gegangen.
Ich habe jetzt einen Manager, ja.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Also jetzt ist wirklich, also die Stonks gehen ganz steil nach oben.
Ja, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Ja, du kannst dir ruhig auch einen Manager-Kicks-Emote designen lassen.
Dann machen wir Wupp-Vetris oder so.
Willst du Halo on Stream?
Ja, vielleicht.
Ich habe mir sogar überlegt, ob ich es heute mal anschmeiße.
Okay, aber jetzt mal zum eigentlichen Thema.
Also wir können uns jetzt, den können wir auch nehmen.
Also wir können uns jetzt, ja, richtig abgehoben, ne?
Ne, sag abgedreht, abgehoben ist doch so die neueste Geschichte, wie man das bezeichnet.
Sagt man eigentlich noch belastend?
Das war mal eine Zeit lang voll im Trend, dass man gesagt hat, belastend.
Aber das ist glaube ich nicht mehr so angesagt, oder?
Subreddit-Ansehen.
Oh, das wird, das Battlefield 2042 Subreddit ist ziemlich am eskalieren.
Oder wie sagt man da so auf Englisch zu am Circle Jerken?
Die sind wirklich komplett am eskalieren.
Es ist auch so ein kleines Battle-Entbrannt zwischen dem normalen Battlefield Subreddit
und dem Battlefield 2042 Subreddit.
Check mal Steam.
Haben wir letztens schon geguckt?
Wir haben auch Metacritic geguckt.
Und Battlefield.
Die sind, oh guck mal, es geht hoch, es geht hoch.
Vor ein paar Tagen waren es so 25%, gestern waren es 26%, heute 27%.
Aber ja, wie sieht's?
Moment, SteamStats, New World, die wichtigste täglich New World Kontrolle.
Die kacken so ab.
Jetzt wollte ich jetzt noch gucken.
Ach so, Metacritic.
Okay, es ist nicht schlechter geworden.
Es steht immer noch bei 2,3.
Das ist so mies, Alter.
Wie ist eigentlich Call of Duty Vanguard?
Hier übrigens erst mal richtiger Oldschooler hier mit dem Turbo.
Das kann man glaube ich umstellen in seinem Profil, aber es hat kaum noch einer die Turbo-Anzeige.
Richtig.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aktuell dieses Jahr ist es glaube ich eher, dass sich Vanguard und Battlefield unter,
also übertreffen wollen, im Negativ-Hate-Up bekommen.
Ansonsten, ich hab mir es nicht gekauft.
Das erste Call of Duty seit einer ganzen Weile, die ich mir nicht gekauft habe.
So Leute, jetzt könnt ihr es euch überlegen.
Ich muss jetzt mal zum Punkt kommen, weil bald ist schon spät und ihr wisst, was dann ist.
Wir können jetzt zwei Sachen machen.
Wir gucken uns heute auf jeden Fall Black Friday Deals an,
weil ich brauche eine SSD und ich will mal gucken, ob beispielsweise die Amazon Fire TV-Dinger noch deploadbar sind.
Ob sich das aktuell lohnt zu kaufen.
Vielleicht machen wir das am Freitag auch noch mal.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Zumindest.
Also wir können euch jetzt zwei Sachen überlegen.
Entweder wir gucken jetzt erstmal Black Friday Deals, das machen wir heute auf jeden Fall.
Oder ich lasse mich mal über ein paar aktuelle Comments auf YouTube aus,
weil da gibt es einige Dinge, die ich dazu sagen will.
Wie gesagt, wir wissen ja laut YouTube-Comments, ich zeige es euch mal.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Wir wissen ja laut YouTube-Comments, dass ich mittlerweile auf einer Ebene mit Jens Spahn bin.
Falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet, ich zeige euch das mal schnell.
Community.
Sort by.
Moment, wo ist er?
Wo ist er denn?
Hier, da ist er.
Also hier.
Also er ist mega angepisst.
Er ist mega angepisst.
Die Frage auf YouTube war ja,
wo das die Leute abstimmen konnten, wie das übernächste Video aussieht.
Und ich habe halt gesagt, vorher muss ich noch ein Hazard Zone Sponsored Video machen.
Und da kam er, er hat hier gesagt, ja gut, dass du gegen IELFlames.
Und da kam er hier richtig an und hat sich mega ausgekotzt.
Das ist eigentlich Sponsored, wieder Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
So.
Es gibt ein paar coole Comments, wozu ich was sagen wollte.
Sowohl zu diesen Sponsored Video Themen als auch eben zu
generell Content Creator und Battlefield, Battlefield Zeug.
Paul ist aktiv.
Nice.
Zeig mal her.
Was machen wir als erstes?
YouTube Comments Rant Black Friday Deal.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das wird kein YouTube Comments Rant.
Ich möchte auch mal ein paar neue Punkte ansprechen.
Zum Beispiel, dass ich denke, dass durchaus Content Creator
ziemlich einen Einfluss drauf haben auf die ganze Geschichte.
Allerdings anders als man denkt.
Da machen wir so, weil das ja quasi so ein bisschen,
Black Friday Deals überwiegen, aber das andere auch.
Da gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal an, ob ich ein paar Sachen finde,
die ich eh schon suche die ganze Zeit bei Amazon.
Und bevor wir dann weiter gucken, machen wir YouTube Comments Rant
und dann machen wir weiter mit Deals.
Da sage ich gleich was zu.
Das sind genauso Dinger, wozu ich gleich was sagen will.
Okay.
Die Umfrage geht zwar noch eine Weile, aber ich glaube,
der Trend ist relativ klar.
So, also was ich unbedingt brauche ist, wir können ja gleich mal gucken,
wie es dann wirklich ausgeht, also was ich unbedingt brauche
und wo Black Friday eigentlich ganz nice ist, sind SSDs.
Ich habe es hier letzten schon gezeigt.
Ich brauche unbedingt am besten eine externe SSD,
1-2TB zum Captchern von Videos.
Ich habe aktuell eine, ich meine, ich habe riesen SSD-Sammelsurium
eigentlich mittlerweile am Rechner hängen, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt.
Ich habe eine interne, glaube ich, 8TB Platte.
Da mache ich quasi Videoränder drauf und sowas.
Aber ich mag das lieber auf eine SSD aufnehmen,
weil SSDs halt nicht irgendwelche Slowdowns zwischendurch haben
und das Video dann ruckelt beim Aufnehmen.
Das ist halt immer doof.
Ich habe eine 8TB Platte.
Ich habe eine 512G System-SSD.
Ich habe, glaube ich, eine 2TB M2-SSD.
Ich habe eine externe, glaube ich, auch 2TB M2-SSD an einem USB zu M2-Dings-Converter.
Aber alles schon belegt mit VMs und hier Streaming-Geschichten und sonst was.
Und ich bräuchte jetzt eine, die ich wirklich dedicated,
die verschlüssel ich auch nicht oder sowas,
die ich dedicated, oder vielleicht doch.
Wie gesagt, ich sage ja immer, ich verschlüssel alles,
die ich dedicated verwende zum Aufnehmen.
Und da hätte ich gerne am besten meine stinknormale USB-SSD.
Fertig.
ChainLore, da bist du ja.
Wir haben auf dich gewartet.
Kann das sein, dass du whoop-arrive gelöscht hast?
Es gibt nur noch whoop-leave. Es gibt kein whoop-arrive mehr.
Falls ja, ist es nicht schlimm.
Ich will ja nicht Common-Slots bei dir blockieren.
Aber es wäre gut, wenn du mir whoop-arrive schicken könntest.
Dann kann ich das hier nämlich als GIF-Emote reinmachen.
Die sind jetzt nämlich alle weg.
Whoop-arrive gibt es nämlich nicht mehr.
Okay, Matt, wie gesagt, danach soll ich mal gucken.
Aber nur, wenn es Black Friday Deals gibt.
Crucial.
Meinst du die?
2TB. Die ist aber nicht Black Friday Dealed, oder?
Woran erkennt man jetzt, ob die Black Friday Dealed ist oder nicht?
An der Geschichte hier, oder was?
Aber das ist doch bestimmt G-Baded. Wenn man mal bei Geiz-Hals guckt,
ist das garantiert wieder G-Bade.
Das ist garantiert G-Bade. So 1TB kostet...
Ja, okay, ist doch tatsächlich relativ günstig.
Ja, dann ist doch der Weiter-Trend hier eindeutig zu erkennen.
Dann machen wir das so.
Wir gucken jetzt erst mal ein paar Deals.
Dann lasse ich meinen YouTube-Gramm ab.
Und dann machen wir noch ein paar weitere Deals,
bevor wir den Job wechseln.
Weil wir müssen natürlich auch bei den China-Chinesen gucken.
Das ist ja klar.
Kekomret und...
Ja, was ist eigentlich die passende China-Variante von Kekomret?
Kekereisfeld, keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Stimmt, ihr habt recht.
Eigentlich schon.
Ja, die habe ich gesehen.
Die habe ich sogar im letzten Stream gesehen.
Hab gedacht, die kaufe ich jetzt, aber ich habe sie nicht gekauft.
War richtig hängen geblieben.
Worauf sollte man bei Festplatten...
Ach, da hat irgendjemand geschrieben gerade.
Worauf sollte man im Kauf von Festplatten...
Also bei Festplatten gibt es, glaube ich,
nur 2 Hersteller auf der Welt noch.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich...
Ja.
Da gibt es nicht so viel, worauf du achten musst.
Bei SSDs, eigentlich kann man da gar nicht so viel verkehrt machen.
Das Einzige, wo man wirklich in die Tonne greifen kann,
sind USB-Sticks oder Mikro-SSD-Karten und sowas.
Weil USB-Sticks sind teilweise einfach der übelste Crap.
Gerade diese billigen USB-Sticks, Leute.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal den USB-Stick.
Den hatte jeder von uns schon mal in der Hand.
Hier.
Diese USB-Sticks.
Jeder.
Jeder hatte diese USB-Sticks schon mal.
Ich meine, das ist nicht explizit mit diesem Hersteller drauf,
sondern die Form und dieses Ding zum Drehen.
Jeder.
Jeder hatte so ein Ding schon mal.
Und die sind halt Dreck.
Die sind richtig Dreck.
Was anderes kann man nicht sagen.
Die gibt es ja in zig Varianten.
Wenn man bei AliExpress mal USB-Stick eingibt
und man sollte bei AliExpress tunlich nicht
Huge-USB eingeben.
Das haben wir ja gelernt.
Ihr wisst, was rauskommt, wenn man Huge-USB eingibt.
Guckt hier.
Das sind die China-Chinesen-USB-Sticks.
Für 1 Cent das Stück.
Das spricht schon unglaublich für Qualität.
Wobei das stimmt ja nicht.
Das ist ja Erstbesteller-Dings-Rabatt.
Bis zu einem Stück pro Kunde ist doch Schwachsinn.
Warum?
Hast du die nicht mal mit zur Arbeit gebracht?
Doch. Woher weißt du das?
Hab ich das erzählt?
Ja.
Die habe ich mal mit zur Arbeit gebracht.
Ein 20er-Pack USB-Sticks.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste ist?
Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
aber ich glaube, ich habe bis heute
nicht das Geld dafür bekommen.
Ja, darauf sollte man tatsächlich gucken,
was es für Speicherzellen sind.
Das stimmt. Bei SSDs, ja.
Wobei rein als Videograb ist das sicherlich auch okay.
Du hast deine HDD bei Wish bestellt.
Ich meine, das ist fake.
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Aber es gibt Leute, die machen das.
Und mir ist die Existenzberechtigung von Wish bis heute nicht klar.
Wish ist doch einfach nur da,
dass Leute YouTube-Videos darüber machen können und rummemen.
Ansonsten hat Wish doch nicht wirklich
irgendeine Daseinsberechtigung.
Wish ist einfach nur für Leute,
die zu blöd sind, selbst in China zu bestellen
und aus irgendwelchen Gründen glauben,
Wish kann besser in China bestellen als sie selbst.
Was hältst du davon, dass es immer mehr USB-C gibt?
Ja, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich kann dir da leider gar nichts raten,
weil oftmals sind viele USB-Sticks einfach Schrott.
Entweder werden sie mega heiß,
sind bei China USB-Sticks teilweise gefaked.
So nach dem Motto, das ist ein 2TB USB-Stick,
in Wirklichkeit sind 32G drin und sowas.
Da muss man einfach mal testlesen.
Ich kann dir da leider nichts empfehlen.
Bonus für Neulinge, dachte ich mir.
Ja, beides schon.
USB-Stick kann ich mir auch dran erinnern,
sogar ein richtig guter von Crucial damals.
Das war so ein Crucial,
so ein USB-Stick mit Gummi und roten Streifen,
der sah so richtig high-tech aus,
war aber nur USB-Stick.
Das war so ein USB-Stick mit Gummi und roten Streifen,
der sah so richtig high-tech aus,
war aber nur USB-Stick mit Gummi und roten Streifen,
der ist mir mal verreckt.
Und wisst ihr auch warum?
Weil ich was total bescheuertes gemacht habe.
Ich habe einen Ubuntu-Server installiert
auf zwei USB-Sticks im Raid 1.
Hat jemand sowas schon mal gemacht?
USB-Sticks Raid 1?
Das ist keine gute Idee,
kann ich euch im Nachhinein sagen.
Kannst du sogar direkt im Ubuntu-Server
installieren, das wird offiziell supportet.
Kannst du sogar direkt im Ubuntu-Server installieren, das wird offiziell supportet.
USB-Stick Raid 1, gar kein Ding.
Ja, ok, das stimmt, das stimmt,
du hast recht, dauerhaft ein,
aber dauerhaft ein bei einer SSD heißt immer noch
irgendwie 170 MB die Sekunde.
Ich habe hier nämlich so eine Saandisk.
Fragt mich nicht, bla,
so eine schwarze Saandisk-Platte.
Und da ist das auch so, aber das reicht mir immer noch.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass ich jetzt
Mist erzähle und wenn es weiter ein
bricht, dann ist es wirklich Müll.
Du hattest einen Raspberry Pi mit 2 USB-Sticks
Raid 0 als NAS 8, du Scheiße.
Weißt du was zumfaßen?
Es war klar, dass es Leute schon gemacht haben.
4 Tera Byte, ja,
8 Tera Byte,
das ist halt
fast schon zu teuer, ich habe mir auch
ob ich sowas kaufen soll.
Oh, das ist natürlich Müll, das ist natürlich Müll.
Wie soll Raid 1 denn einen USB Stick kaputt machen?
Ne, das Raid 1 ist nicht das Problem gewesen, das Problem war, dass da halt einfach relativ
viel drauf geschrieben wurde.
Es war aber halt in einem Raid 1, deswegen kann ich mich da noch dran erinnern, das
Raid 1 ist nicht das Problem.
Das Raid 1 hat es nicht kaputt gemacht, aber im Zweifelsfall sind die USB Sticks auch noch
bei ähnlicher Daten, beim ähnlichen Datenschreibvolumen kaputt und ich hatte Glück, dass der andere
nicht auch abgekackt ist.
Wie funktioniert Raid Max, denn da würde ich mir den Wikipedia Artikel mal angucken,
da kann ich das nicht großartig erklären.
Ja, korrekt, Raid 1 ist einfach kopieren.
Das kann ich dir jetzt so im Kurzfassung, ok, die Kurzfassung von Raid.
Die Kurzfassung von Raid ist, wenn du nicht weißt, was Raid ist, dann brauchst du in
der Regel kein Raid.
Klingt übelst doof und abgehoben und überheblich, ich weiß, aber es ist in dem Fall echt so.
Weil ansonsten kommt man zum Beispiel auf die Idee und sagt, man macht einen Raid 1
und braucht keinen Backup mehr und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, die ganz kurze Variante von Raid ist, du hast verschiedene Raid Levels, das einfachste
Raid Level ist, du hast zwei Platten, schreibst immer die Hälfte der Datei auf eine, die
Hälfte der Datei auf eine andere, das ist Raid 0, auch Kamikaze Raid genannt, wenn eine
der Platten kaputt ist, dann ist alles im Arsch, dann hast du Raid 1, da schreibst du bei den
Zugriffen immer alles doppelt auf beide Platten, das heißt, eine kann kaputt gehen und es
läuft weiter, du hast unterschiedliche Vor- und Nachteile bei den ganzen Geschichten natürlich
und dann hast du noch verschiedene andere Raid Levels, die ja alles Kompromisse sind
zwischen Raid 0 und Raid 1 im Endeffekt, also quasi immer so Kompromisse zwischen, wie
viele Platten muss ich opfern dafür, dass ich quasi Ausfallssicherheit bekomme und sowas,
aber Raid 0 und 1 sind so die Extreme, Raid 0 ist quasi Performance, dafür Instant RIP
wenn was kaputt ist und Raid 1 ist quasi Sicherheit, aber nicht so viel Performance, wobei das
auch nicht stimmt, da kommt ja dazu, dass Leseraten mit Raid 1 auch steigen und sowas, aber das
alles andere sind Kompromisse dazwischen.
Jaylott hat ein Bild gepostet, Wuppo Rife ist wieder da, Pog, heißt das du machst nicht
mehr rein, ich solls runterladen, mach ich, mach ich lade es runter, nee das ist ein neues
Wuppo Rife oder, gleich Wuppo Rife, ich speichere mir das, danke, Pog, was hältst du eigentlich
von SLI und Crossfire nicht mehr so ported, ja braucht man eh nicht, kennst du dich mit
ZFS aus, nur sehr rudimentär, so aber jetzt gucken wir mal, also wie gesagt diese billig
USB Sticks hat ja wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal, na dann, so, also meine Backups mach
ich auf Magnetplatten tatsächlich, ich hab ne 12TB Magnetplatte drinne hängen und da
kommt das alles drauf, so das lohnt sich nicht so wirklich, die spricht mich nicht so wirklich
an, muss ich mal warten ob es da was anderes gibt, was haben wir sonst noch für schöne
SSDs hier bei Black Friday erstellt, die üblichen Verdächtigen, das ist auch der Dauerbrenner
bei SSDs oder, das Ding gibt es auch schon irgendwie gefühlt 120 Jahre, sieht genauso
aus und ist immer beliebt, davon hab ich auch 3 Stück hier rumfliegen, aber in der kleineren
Variante, ah was ist das denn für exquisite Musik da im Hintergrund, ah jetzt, erstmal
kurz den Rotwein holen, so, nein das ist kein Rotwein, das ist Himbeersaft, also es ist
nicht Himbeersaft, es ist Wasser mit einem Schluck Himbeersaft drinne, also es ist nicht
so lahmarsch geschmeckt, dafür ist Twitch ja da, das ist ja auch der schöne Vorteil
gegenüber Twitch zu Youtube, man ist live dabei, so, aber es ist nichts dabei, wir gucken
mal auf der Amazon Startseite ob es da irgendwas gescheit, es gibt Black Friday Week, ja zeig
her, Fire TV Stick, ey die bloaten den Fire TV Stick auch immer weiter, ich hab mir vor
2 Jahren einen Fire TV Stick gekauft, aber nicht witzigerweise um den Fire TV Stick zu
verwenden, sondern weil es im Angebot war, ich hab die Fernbedienung verwendet für mein
Shield TV, aber mittlerweile ist die Fernbedienung ja sowas von bloated, bei der Fernbedienung
die ich habe ist das hier oben drauf, aber der Kram da unten ist noch nicht am Start,
ja was der neue Linux Kernel soll jetzt besser Linux Gaming supporten, aha, inwiefern, das
funktioniert, ja das ist Bluetooth, das ist ein Bluetooth Gerät, du kannst die ohne Probleme
pairen mit deinem Shield TV, das funktioniert, funktioniert, leider gibt es andere Probleme,
die Bluetooth Geräte entpairen sich laufend mal oder sind da nicht mehr erreichbar oder,
meinst du mit Shield Nvidia Shield, ja ich meine das Shield TV, meine ich das da, Shield,
nicht der Zigaretten Anzünder, sondern das da, ich hab hier noch das Shield, das Shield
TV von 2017 glaube ich, sieht man doch, warte mal, ich hab doch da sogar mal ein Video,
Shield TV, ich hab doch genau, ich hab da sogar mal ein Video drüber gemacht, irgendwo hier,
da, da steht es doch, das meine ich, mit der Nvidia Ente, alter was denn heute los, ich
weiß nicht, Spiegelung im Fernsehen übrigens Leute, hier guck mal, Massive League, schau
doch das mal an, irgendwo hier wird der Bildschirm dunkel und es ist huge, huge League, guckt
mal hier, Massive, da ist er, mit der Kappe auf, Woop League, Face Reveal, aber man sieht
nix, in Zukunft mit Facecam, alles outdated, oh ja das ist schon 3 Jahre her, heute bin
ich bestimmt 5 mal so dick, ne, es ist ungefähr, es hat sich da nicht so viel geändert, es
ist sogar eher ein bisschen weniger geworden, nicht viel, nicht viel, so 5 Kilo weniger,
aber ein bisschen, so, Max hat dicke Arme, ja das ist ja schon eine Klassiker schlechthin,
so, fangen wir mal mit dem an, von dem ich glaube, dass sich das immer lohnt bei Amazon,
wenn es denn, wenn es denn solche Sachen gibt, nämlich die Amazon eigenen Dinger, Amazon
Devices, genau, das kann man nicht im eigenen Tab aufmachen, du hast in 4 Tagen 0,005 2
zu 4 Ethereum gefarmt, das sind, wie viel, 2 Cent, 20 Euro, na immerhin, kannst du jetzt
NFTs kaufen von, da kann man sich ja Bilder von Affen oder Pixel, Pixel Bilder kaufen
für 150.000 Euro, also ich hab den Sinn von NFTs bis heute nicht verstanden, ich glaube,
ich bin da entweder zu alt für oder ich check's einfach nicht, so, ja das kommt dabei, die
Bilder kann man sich ja auch so einfach runterladen, also deswegen verstehe ich, deswegen verstehe
ich nicht, also was ich immer gut bei diesen ganzen Black Friday Dingern bei Amazon finde
ist, wenn man Amazon eigene Devices kaufen will, Problem für mich ist, ich will diesen
ganzen Shit nicht haben, das einzige, was ich ab und zu mal für ganz brauchbar befunden
habe sind die Tablets, allerdings brauche ich aktuell keine, ich wollte mal gucken,
ob es welche gibt, weil wird oft gefragt, das finde ich lohnt sich jetzt, das lohnt sich,
das Fire HD 10 für 80 Euro, davon habe ich auch 2 Stück, nämlich als Home Automation
Dashboard, einmal hier oben im Flur und einmal unten im Flur, allerdings, das lohnt sich
auch nur, wenn man die Fire TV Toolbox nimmt, oder Fire Toolbox, wenn man das hier nimmt
und damit, die mittlerweile einen roten Hintergrund hat anscheinend, und damit sein Gerät deploatet,
es heißt, guckt vorher nach, ob das auch unterstützt wird bei eurem Gerät, weil da kann man alles
mögliche runterschmeißen, kann die ganzen Apps runterschmeißen, man kann die Werbung
von Amazon wegmachen, das ist bestimmt nicht im Sinne von Amazon, aber letztendlich soll
sich Amazon aber nicht so sehr beschweren, ihr kauft ja wenigstens das Gerät und außerdem
kauft ihr genug wahrscheinlich andere Sachen bei Amazon, und der eine oder andere kauft
sich und benutzt es trotzdem im Stock weiter, ja, aber ich finde, das lohnt sich preislich
eigentlich ganz gut.
Der Chat sagt, der hat es vor einer, sollte man das nicht gleich, nein, nein, nein, weil,
also erstens, ja, das ist teurer, wenn du es ohne Wärmung kaufst, das kostet dann
sogar null, 20 Euro mehr, ich glaube, es geht los, nein, nicht ganz, 15 Euro mehr, aber du
hast es hier immer noch Amazon gedönst, also du hast die ganzen Apps und alles, und wenn
du es deploatest, ist es einfach besser, so, 80 Euro für das Tablet, was von der Hardware
ganz okay ist, also vor allem für den Preis, und deploatet ist das eine richtig gute Geschichte.
Lustigerweise ist nach dem deploaten dieses Tablet nicht mehr wirklich gut geeignet für
Amazon, klingt jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich, aber Amazon erkennt bei den Apps natürlich,
wenn die auf dem Fire Tablet laufen und möchte dann die im Betriebssystem integrierte Anmeldung
zum Beispiel verwenden, dabei möchte man sich ja mit dem Tablet, wenn man es deploatet
hat, explizit nicht mehr bei Amazon einloggen, das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Also, wenn man da mit Amazon Prime Video gucken will, oder die Amazon Shopping App verwenden
will, dann ist das nicht das beste, deswegen verwende ich die auch nicht als normale Tablets,
sondern als Home Automation Dashboards, und dafür sind die echt gut, ich habe oben hier
im Flur, eigentlich im Prinzip direkt vor der Tür, also vor dem Arbeitszimmer, neben
der Türgegensprecheranlage, habe ich so eins hängen mit meinem Home Automation Dashboard
drauf und unten im Flur auch, dafür sind die Dinger super, Geschwindigkeit, so kann man
sich nicht beschweren, beim Einsatz als Home Automation Dashboard ist halt wichtig, dass
die eine USB Stromversorgung haben, klappt das nicht, nein, nein, die haben keinen normalen
Play Store, aber das kannst du alles installieren mit der Toolbox, zum YouTube schauen, ja also
ich sehe schon, der Chat, warum von Amazon, hast du andere Amazon Geräte, ja warum von
Amazon, das ist ganz einfach, weil das preisleistungsmäßig gut ist, für Android Tablets, zum benutzen
verwende ich eigentlich Tablet technisch keine Android Geräte mehr, obwohl ich insgesamt
glaube ich 11 oder 12 oder sogar 13, mittlerweile insgesamt Tablets und Smartphones hier rum
fliegen habe, mit der Zeit, auch ein Großteil davon Android, aber im Tablet Bereich muss
ich sagen, hat sich bei mir eher so die iPad Geschichte durchgesetzt, nicht wegen der
Sicherheit, ich finde, dass ich einfach von der Bedienung her auf dem Tablet iOS besser
anfühle, auf dem Smartphone kann man sich da vielleicht schreiten, aber man kann jeder
verwenden was er will, ich will es ja keinem vorschreiben, bei mir persönlich iOS in der
Bedienung lieber, aber es hat natürlich alles seine Vor- und Nachteile, wie man auch daran
sieht, dass man als Dashboard an der Wand, wie machst du das mit dem Wall Mount, ich
habe Glück, meine Türgegensprechanlage hängt so, dass ich es eigentlich nur noch daneben
hinklemmen kann, ich habe absichtlich aber ein Android Tablet an der Wand, weil Android
wird sich um ein Vielfaches besser automatisieren lassen, wie iOS, also iOS kannst du nicht
richtig automatisieren, iOS muss alles immer durch Usergesten und solche Geschichten ausgelöst
werden, das kann man auch nicht umgeben, das ist quasi Philosophie von Apple, das wollen
die so, bei Android kannst du alles machen, automatisches Logscreen entsperren, automatische
Apps starten mit Tasker, eine MQTT Message irgendwo hinschicken, so nach dem, mein Bildschirm
ist jetzt angegangen, das kannst du mit iOS alles nicht gescheit machen, mit Android geht
das, deswegen sind meine Home Automation Dashboards Android Tablets und mein Tablet zum täglichen
benutzten iOS und das ist das, was ich auch immer sage, es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn,
letztendlich ob jetzt Google oder Apple, das nimmt sich doch alles nix, also es ist weder
so, dass du sagen kannst, oh ich google eine geile Firma, noch dass du sagen kannst, oh
Apple eine geile Firma, unterm Strich hat es keinen Sinn die Hardware-Auswahl nach irgendwelchen,
in dem Fall wenn es alles Drecksläden sind, nach irgendwelchen ideologischen Sachen zu
treffen oder Fanboy Sachen, sondern man sollte einfach das nehmen, was am besten für das
jeweilige Anwendungsgebiet ist, ich habe keine Ahnung, G-Bested, das ist relativ neu, das
gibt bestimmt erst eine Woche, habe ich glaube ich vor 1-2 Tagen das erste Mal gesehen.
Genau, das macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied, also das finde ich lohnt sich richtig, den
anderen Crap, den es hier so gibt, oh ich vergesse immer, wir sind ja auf Twitch, das
ist ja alles Amazon hier eigentlich, ja gut da müssen sie jetzt durch, diesen anderen
Crap, den es hier gibt, ist persönlich überhaupt nichts für mich, ich habe kein Alexa-Stells
am Start, ich habe auch kein Echo am Start oder was ist Bilderrahmen oder irgendwie Türklingel
oder was es da noch alles gibt, da habe ich auch Lösungen, aber hier nichts von den Amazon-Geräten
und auch keine Google Nest oder so ein Müll, da halte ich wenig von, deswegen das einzig
interessante für mich hier sind die Tablets und dann auch nur die Plotted, vielleicht
noch Firestick, wenn man da scharf drauf ist, ja aber das würde ich auch nicht einsetzen,
so was haben wir hier sonst noch so viele Sachen, Shopping Deals All, Computer und Hardware,
hatten die nicht auch mal eine Smart Home Kategorie, wo ist denn die hin, seht ihr die,
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wir haben das letzte Mal Smart Home geguckt, wo ist denn
die hin, gibt es hier nicht mehr, ist das vielleicht hier drin, wo sind die Smart Homes
Sachen drin, hm witzig mehr oder, sind bestimmt nicht unter Girl Fashion, Home, Home Kitchen,
Home TV, Home and Cinema, Interesse, das gibt es nicht mehr, ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass
es das letzte Mal noch so eine Smart Home Kategorie gab, komisch, vielleicht hat sich
nicht gut genug verkauft, kein Schimmer, so das wird wahrscheinlich das übliche sein
wie bei allen Black Friday Weeks, Black Friday Deals, Black Friday Monaten und Black Friday
Quartalen oder wieviel es da mittlerweile gibt, das 99,9% absoluter Müll ist, den kein Mensch
braucht, aber ein paar gute Deals sind wahrscheinlich doch dabei, gucken wir mal ob wir irgendwie
suchen können nach Black Friday Smart Home, ich gebe ja immer ganz gerne meinen Senf dazu,
was es da so gibt, weil das meiste ist Müll, wahrscheinlich auch Müll, ist es Zigbee,
dann ist wahrscheinlich Müll, ich habe noch kein einziges gute Zigbee Thermostat gefunden,
was ist das denn, zeig mal her, es ist ein Custom Protokoll, ok das ist ja noch schlechter,
das ist noch mehr Müll, Switchbot, die Dinger sind nice, wenn es da welche gibt würde ich
tatsächlich empfehlen welche zu kaufen, wenn man in diesem Smart Home Gedöns unterwegs
ist, die Dinger sind wirklich cool, ich zeige euch mal was man damit machen kann, das ist
für Dinger die sich nicht gescheit automatisieren lassen, guckt euch das an, das ist einfach
ein Gerät was für euch Schalter drücken kann, kommt ins Wlan und kann für euch Schalter
drücken, also wenn man irgendwas nicht so smartes hat, was sich nicht so einfach automatisieren
lässt, ist das Ding wirklich richtig Pock, guckt, genau und es ist zwei Wege, man kann
das mit so einem Klebepad auch rausziehen wieder, das ist wirklich cool, also wenn man
zum Beispiel, es muss ja nicht ein Lichtschalter sein, aber Lichtschalter ist zum Beispiel
ein ganz gutes Beispiel für, wenn man da kein Celly rein machen will oder wirklich das alles
so lassen wie du willst, ist das eine gute Idee, das eignet sich natürlich auch für
alle möglichen anderen Geräte von Tiefkühltruhe, gut muss man Tiefkühltruhe so oft einen ausschalten,
zweites doofes Beispiel, Kaffeemaschine bis sonst was, also überall da wo es eine Wlan
Dose nicht tut, für ein Herd eher nicht, Herd kann man damit zum Beispiel nicht drücken,
aber dafür ist das wirklich gut und wenn ich das jetzt sehe, da würde ich mir tatsächlich,
wenn die gibt es relativ selten bei Amazon in Deutschland zu kaufen, da würde ich mir
tatsächlich, was sind das 20 Euro, das ist natürlich nicht billig, aber so ein Dreierpark
wünsche ich mir tatsächlich da nochmal von kaufen, no thanks, die Frage ist jetzt nur,
was kosten die denn nochmal, schauen wir mal mal, Geizhals, Switchbot, Onkess, Boomer Augen,
ich sehe doch da nichts mehr, ja, das gibt es sogar nur bei Amazon, also wer auf sowas
steht kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen, das ist eines der besten Smart Home Gadgets für
Geräte, die man nicht so einfach automatisieren kann, du musst dir mal einen Kepa Plugin in
den, was für den den, weiß ich gar nicht was das sein soll, ein Amazon Price Tracker, ja,
das tatsächlich wäre nicht schlecht für sowas, dachte das ist Kappa Emotes auf jeder Seite
oder so, kann das Switchbot an MQTT, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, ich glaube standardmäßig
nicht, aber es gibt Integrations die das für dich machen, der Kram kommt ins WLAN und du
kannst den glaube ich per WLAN, du kannst den aber glaube ich auch per Bluetooth vom
Smartphone steuern, aber es gibt Steuerungen, die kannst du, also es gibt für Switchbot
Home Assistant, es gibt eine fertige Integration und ach nee, die machen das über Bluetooth
tatsächlich, ok, das aber auch nicht wild, da machen sie es über Bluetooth, es gibt
allerdings auch garantiert Integrations, wenn dein Switchbot zu weit weg ist, dass du da
nicht mit BLE hinkommst, wo du MQTT schicken kannst und irgendwas schaltet dann in der
Nähe, 100%ig, also Switchbot ist mittlerweile relativ, gibt es schon relativ lange und ist
auch relativ verbreitet, das heißt da wirst du Sachen für finden, ziemlich sicher, gucken
wir mal, ja, guck gibt es sogar einen fertigen ESP32-Sketch, brauchst einen 2,50 Euro Controller,
haust das drauf und kannst es dann über MQTT steuern, hat sogar Home Assistant Discovery,
da kann man sich wirklich nicht beschweren, irgendeinen ESP32 nehmen, den Sketch drauf
machen, fertig ist es, geht, easy, müssten wir tatsächlich, schreibe ich mal auf, das
probieren wir mal aus, jetzt ist der Moment, wo der Chat wieder sagen kann, ha, null,
Max, dein Desktop, Stream Ideen, Switchbot, BLE, ESP32, MQTT, alles klar, probieren wir
mal aus, kann ich mal die Kamera anmachen, Handleak, finde den gekommen, ja, da ist
er, das ist so easy, direkt gefunden, desktop, DeadPie79, danke für den Sub, huge Subscription
hier, ok, also wie gesagt, das kann ich empfehlen, das ist wirklich nice, eufi, also diese Kameras
kommen mir nicht ins Haus, ich hab einen eufi Saugroboter, einen ganz alten, das war der
ersten, den ich gekauft habe, so ein ganz blöder, der eigentlich immer nur die permanent
gegen die Wand fährt und irgendwann auch den Raum durch hat, den benutze ich tatsächlich
ab und zu noch für unter die Schränke, weil unter die Schränke kommen alle andere nicht
drunter, nur der oldschool eufi Roboter kommt da unten drunter, habe ich ja nicht so gerne
so, da habe ich doch mal so ein gachibus, was, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
es ist, das ist der neue, das ist der neue, der bleibt auch nicht mehr an die ecke hängen,
ich finde es nicht, ich hatte da eigentlich ganz lustiges Video, wo der staubsauger Roboter
quasi den Kratzbaum Gatschi Bust hat, der hatte so ein bisschen Probleme um den Kratzbaum
rumzukommen.
Gatschi Bust, dieses Wort gibt es doch eigentlich auch nur auf Twitch, oder?
Ich glaube niemand auf der Welt, überlegt euch mal ernsthaft, ihr sagt irgendwo, der
Staubsauger Roboter hat den Kratzbaum Gatschi Bust, versteht irgendjemand der nicht auf
Twitch ist und was es geht, es verstehen dann die meisten Leute, die auf Twitch sind, wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal um was es geht.
Letztens hat Gatschi gesagt, das glaube ich dir sofort.
Ich sage mittlerweile auch so komische Dinge in real life, allerdings ist es, ich kann
es kaum noch auseinander halten.
Ich meine es ist vielleicht nicht so schlimm wie bei XQC, der irgendwie einkaufen geht
und sagt, it's Pog, oder irgendwie sowas, oder get the juice, oder irgendwie sowas, aber
bei mir hat sich eindeutig auch Twitchspeak in den täglichen Sprachgebrauch eingeschlichen.
Poggers hört sich an wie jemand der 40 und versucht cool zu sein, meinst du mich?
Okay ich bin noch nicht ganz 40, ich bin noch nicht ganz 40, du kannst ja mich nicht
meinen.
Ihr müsst in die Prime Sub Abo Falle gehen, noch bin ich ja nicht 40, okay, irgendwelche
komischen Anschlüsse, wo ich gar nicht weiß, ob wir die in Deutschland haben, keine Ahnung,
haben wir, haben wir, das sind nicht die komischen Inda Anschlüsse, das sind, frag mich aber
nicht für was, keine Ahnung, äh, China-Chinesen-RGB Kram, braucht man nicht, Bose zeug ist meistens
auch wahnsinnig overpriced, kommt mir nicht ins Haus, Bizzle, Spinwave, Robot, was?
Spinwave, Robot, ich hab keine Ahnung was das sein soll, nichts was man haben will wahrscheinlich,
für Deckenlampen, GU10 habe ich noch nie gehört, äh, okay, schon ein Schalter eingebaut, Smart
Sockets, aha, aha, die Frage, Tasmota Flashbar oder nicht, damit steht und fällt ja die Eignung
für mein Smart Home oder nicht, Tasmota, ja oder nein, da müssen wir gleich mal suchen,
Tasmota, nix gefunden, bam geht nicht, crap, next, braucht man alles nicht, braucht man
alles nicht, braucht man alles nicht, braucht man nicht, braucht man nicht, Batterien, ja
gut, weiß man wenn man braucht, ja, warum muss es unbedingt Tasmota sein, muss es nicht,
muss es nicht, es kann aber auch irgendeine x-beliebige andere Firmware sein, allerdings
ist Tasmota die bekannteste, wenn man danach sucht und Tasmota sich flashen lässt, lässt
sich auch alles andere flashen, aber es muss auf jeden Fall, ähm, geflashed werden, weil
ansonsten ist ja Kilcom und hat China Chinesen Firmware und Cloud angesagt und das will man
ja nicht, die sehen ja hässlich aus, sind die wirklich so orange, ne, guck mal die Steckdosen
sind weiß, warum sind die hier denn orange, was ist denn das schon wieder für, für, für
China Crap, will man nicht, will man auch nicht, ja Meros ist wirklich Realtek, das stimmt,
ich hatte nämlich mal eine Meros Steckdosenleiste, die hab ich aufgeschraubt und hab dann auch
beim draufgucken auf das Modul festgestellt, fuck, es ist ein Realtek Chip, aber zum Thema
Realtek Chip, für alle die dabei waren, wir haben vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit, das
ist glaube ich auch schon 3 Wochen her oder so, haben wir mal versucht so einen ESP32
auszutauschen, gegen den anderen ESP32, bei so einem, ja so einem Ding mit Motor, was man
verwendet, um Ventile auf und zu zu machen, es hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, prinzipiell
hat es funktioniert, aber am Ende hat es nicht funktioniert, das war leider Reinfall, 40
Euro in Sand gesetzt, braucht keiner, braucht keiner, braucht keiner, ah ich kann nach LED,
genau ich guck mal nach LED, ich hab mir nämlich jetzt was für einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft,
ich hab hier seit ein paar Jahren schon RGB, RGB Strips, nee keine RGB Strips, RGB Lichterketten
für einen Weihnachtsbaum mit einem WLED Controller dran, also mit einem Controller
mit WLED geflasht, das heißt da kannst du richtig nice Effekte machen und so was, und
ich hab mir jetzt folgendes gekauft für meinen Weihnachtsbaum, ich hab so nicht ausprobiert,
aber ich bin mal gespannt wie das dieses Jahr ausschaut, und zwar hab ich mir gekauft,
wie heißen die BTG Lighting, ach nee, B Lightning, B, T, BTF, BTF Lightning, Fairy Lights, ja
ich glaub die sind das, ja ich hab mir so ne Kette hier gekauft, 5 Meter, genau 5 Meter,
das sind nur 50 LEDs, waren das nicht 100 die ich hatte, wir haben es doch in WLED zusammen
eingestellt, zumindest das gute an denen ist, man erkennt das nicht auf den ersten Blick,
das gute an denen im Vergleich zu anderen LED Ketten ist folgendes, vergleichen wir
das mal mit normalen LED Strips, normale LED Strips sind entweder sowas, die eignen sich
ja schon mal aus obvies gründen nicht gut für den Weihnachtsbaum, die gibt es zwar
auch wasserdicht, aber allein schon von der Form, der Farbe und dem Handling, dass du
die nicht richtig an den Baum kriegst, eignen die sich natürlich nicht gut für den Weihnachtsbaum,
die andere Form ist die hier, da ist das Problem, dass die zwar von der grünen Farbe und vom
Kabel her ganz gut sind, im Weihnachtsbaum, aber das trotzdem nicht gut aussieht mit diesen
Chips und diesem Grün und diesem richtig ultra fetten Kabel, außerdem stinken die
Dinger so krass wenn du die kaufst, weil die China Chinesen diese Dinger komplett mit
Heißkleber vollgestopft haben und sonst was damit gemacht haben, keine Ahnung, die stinken
so krass, dass du die erstmal 3 Wochen draußen irgendwo in den Stall legen musst bevor du
dir auch nur dran denken kannst, an den Weihnachtsbaum in die Wohnung zu hängen. So und jetzt habe
ich ja folgendes gekauft, das hier, der Vorteil davon versus den anderen Dingern ist, man
erkennt es hier ganz gut, LEDs brauchen ja 3 Leitungen, also adressierbare LEDs brauchen
3 Leitungen, plus, also 5 Volt in dem Fall sind es, 5 Volt DC plus, minus und eine Datenleitung
um die LEDs anzusteuern. Und was die hier gemacht haben ist, die haben ganz dünne Drähte
genommen, lackierte Drähte, lackierte Drähte, also sprich das ist wasserdicht, lackierte
Drähte und haben die LEDs im Prinzip einfach nur auf diese lackierten Drähte drauf gemacht
und so ein bisschen, wahrscheinlich das Heißkleber oder so ein bisschen, so eine kleine Kapsel
drum gemacht. Das heißt, das ist die mit Abstand flexibelste vom Kabel her und dünnste Variante
die ihr kaufen könnt, wenn ihr RGB-LEDs kaufen möchtet, die einzeln ansteuerbar sind. Es
können auch Silikon sein und dann schön Heißkleber drüber, keine Ahnung. Und das eignet sich
wunderbar für Weihnachtsbaum, diese Kabel erkennst du kaum, wenn du die gut im Baum
machst und es ist trotzdem wasserdicht. Und du kannst WLED drauf flaschen auf den Controller
und die damit ansteuern, das ist richtig nice. Ich zeige euch, wenn es soweit ist an Weihnachten
ein Bild von. Also das ist was, was ich tatsächlich empfehlen kann, Frage ist, ist es im Angebot
gerade? Nein. Aber 20 Euro ist okay. Ich meine, du kriegst hier für 20 Euro, du brauchst
einen Controller für sagen wir mal 350, reicht ja jeder x-beliebige, ESP 26 oder ESP 32 und
du brauchst einen Netzteil. Da reicht aber auch ein günstiges so ein Steckernetzteil
5V 2A gut aus, kostet dann nochmal keine Ahnung 5 Euro oder so. Und da hast du für
sagen wir mal 30 Euro eigentlich und mit Open Source Software WLED von GitHub drauf geflasht,
dann hast du eine WLAN-steuerbare Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung, die besser ist als alles, was du dir kommerziell
so kaufen kannst. Und es gibt eigentlich nichts besseres. Number of light. Wo stehts? 505
LEDs. Ja, oh ja, Chat, Chat, das ist richtig, das ist richtig. Das nicht, wobei das eigentlich
auch gar nicht geht, weil du den Pin ja als Strom Input brauchst für einen ESP. Du machst
das ja alles an den Sensoren. Aber ja, man sollte die LEDs nicht versorgen von einem
Pin des ESPs, weil die Pins vom ESP sind glaube ich maximal für 500 milliampere ausgelegt
und das andere mögen die nicht. Ach ja, und wenn mal einer sehen will, wie man mir im
Stream was abgeraucht ist, diesen Clip posten die Leute dann immer gerne, aber ich zeig
es euch auch gerne nochmal. Ja, Rauch. Es hat geplinkt, das plinkt ganz kurz. Ok, habt
ihr es gesehen, ich habe eben nicht hingeguckt, guckt mal. Wow, wow. Smoke, warum? Und jetzt
raucht es. Habt ihr es gesehen, ich habe eben nicht hingeguckt, guckt mal. Also, ja, wir
haben es ja auch schon im Stream geschafft, dass Dinge abgeraucht sind. Lull. Keck, wait.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Ich habe hier die ganzen Lightning, ich bin jetzt
aus den Deals raus. Ok, Computer und Software. Schauen wir mal, was gibt es denn hier Spannendes?
Was gibt es denn hier Gescheites? Ok. Das gucke ich jetzt nochmal schnell durch, bevor
wir weiter gucken, muss ich mich dann aber über YouTube Geschichten auslassen mal schnell.
VLC-Player im Angebot. Oh ja, das habe ich auch gesehen, letztens bei Saturn. Da fragst
ihr dich echt, guckt euch das mal an. Also jeder, der das wirklich kauft, leckt massive
Critical Information. Das ist fast wie die Vollversion von Winra, ja. Auch übrigens
ist keine Lieferung möglich, das heißt, man muss sich den Kram auch noch downloaden. Also
im Prinzip, du kriegst noch nicht mal eine Packung dafür. Was ist da eigentlich der Unterschied?
Tja, nix. Nirgendswo, keine Ahnung. Ok, sogar Chip. Und Leute, ihr könnt euch sicher sein,
wenn Chip über sowas schon berichtet, dann ist das wirklich oldschool, ja. Also wenn
Chip das schon mitgekriegt hat, du bezahlst den Technik, vielleicht gibt es ja einen Installer-Service
oder so. Na ja. Herr Schimmer, was soll das? Na gut, ok, lass mal schnell bei Amazon gucken.
Also, dieses ganze Amazon Zeug, oh guck mal da, Samsung SSDs, vielleicht, ach nee, das
sind keine externen. Oder sind das, ach guck mal da. Was haben wir denn hier? Postchamp.
Was haben wir denn, warum ist denn das so dick, die Anzeige? Warte, ich gehe gleich mal weg.
Hm, das wäre ja schon was, was ich gebrauchen könnte. USB-C? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen
T7 Touch und T7? Ach, das hat ja irgendwie so einen komischen Touch-Sensor, wer braucht
denn sowas? Moment, hatten wir die nicht letztens erst im, ich sehe es da gerade, die haben wir
doch schon im Korb, oder? Kosten die 2TB-Versionen? Jaja, ganz bestimmt, 335, ganz klar. Nochmal
kurz Geizhalz checken. Hier mit der richtig 5-Hat-Musik am Start. Samsung, 2TB, 207.
Hier, das ist gar nicht schlecht, Leute. Das ist gar nicht so, hä? Warum kosten die hier,
jetzt blicke ich mal durch. Die kostet 196,90, die kostet 107. Das ist gar nicht mal schlecht,
ich glaube, das kaufe ich mir. Die Farbe, die Farbe ist das? Tatsächlich, das ist die
Farbe. Ja, du, ich kaufe die auch in rot, das interessiert mich nicht, die Farbe von
SOSD ist mir, will ich nicht so sagen, scheißegal. Das ist nicht schlecht. Propaganda Beef, wo
denn? Ich sehe hier nix billiger. Zeig mal hier, und 200? Nö, ich sehe hier nix günstiger.
Das finde ich aber tatsächlich nicht schlecht. Ach, My Deals? Okay, lass mal gucken, die
haben wir auch auf Samsung. Samsung T7. Zeig mal her. Ab? Nö. Ach hier, nö. Amazon IT,
klar, die bestellen das jetzt in Italien. Ach hier, guck mal da. Ist das die gleiche?
Okay, zum Deal. Mal gucken, wo wir jetzt rauskommen. Cool Blue. Leute, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was das für ein Shop ist. Ich muss mal kurz den Dark wieder ausmachen. Achtung, Flashbang.
Cool Blue. Trendsetter, alles klar. Hat jemand schon bei Cool Blue bestellt? Was, das ist
der Holländische Media Markt, okay. Standard, das ist nichts Geheimes. Ach, das ist eh ausverkauft.
Okay, RIP, vorbei. Komm, dann bestellen wir den Kram jetzt bei Amazon. Amazon, zack, fangeln
wir jetzt nicht lang. Add Basket. Ich muss mal schnell schauen, was ich da noch drinnen
habe, was ich da vom letzten Einkauf in Stream schon von bestellt habe und was nicht. Shopping
Basket, ja guck mal, den habe ich das letzte Mal schon reingelegt. Delete, den lassen wir
drin. Ja, die brauche ich noch. Die Box Vago Clamp und den Super Fluxer, den Mini Super
Fluxer, den brauche ich auch noch. Hab ich auch noch nicht bestellt. Die Soße, das ist
die beste. Ja, Larry, kennst du die? Hast du auch schon mal probiert? Hört sich so an.
Beste Barbecue Soße, Leute. Leider muss man immer abpassen, wenn die gut lieferbar ist
bei Amazon. 11 Euro ist ein wenig übertrieben. Aber die hast du auf meinen Rat gekauft. Siehste,
ich sollte mir sowas Affiliate Links generieren. Aber das ist wirklich eine super Barbecue
Soße und ich bin ja, was das angeht, richtiger Noob gewesen. Ich habe ja früher immer, wenn
ich irgendwelche gegrillten Dinge hatte, ich habe die Barbecue Soße immer, also ich habe
das gegrillt oder gebraten oder was auch immer. Dann habe ich mir auf einen Teller gemacht
und dann habe ich Barbecue Soße dabei gekippt, was ja eigentlich komplett falsch ist, bis
ich dann irgendwann mal gelernt habe, dass man die Barbecue Soße oben drauf macht und
das Ding mit der Barbecue Soße grillt. Und das schmeckt tatsächlich dann auch noch besser.
Cringe, Cringe, wer Barbecue Soße auf den Teller macht, ja. Jetzt wissen es natürlich
alle wieder besser. Jetzt sind es alle wieder so mal so sagen, das hätte ich dir gleich
sagen können. Obvious, Obvious, wie kann man das nur für mich verstehen. Aber ja, ich habe
es nicht gecheckt. Aber die ist wirklich gut. Allerdings nicht für den Preis. Ich meine,
nur guck mal, 32 Euro Liter. Dafür kannst du ja mittlerweile schon deine Ölheizung voll
machen. Ah nee, bei den aktuellen Preisen eher nicht. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ordentlich.
Willkommen im Club, ja. Ja, und den Mini Fluxer, der Name ist so geil, der Mini Fluxer, den
brauche ich immer noch. Guck mal, der Mini Fluxer ist sogar noch teurer. Der Mini Fluxer
kostet 1000 Euro der Liter. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Wer sich fragt, was das ist,
das ist Flussmittel, wenn man was löten will. Kann man dann drauf pinseln mit dem Stift
und wenn man dann darauf was löht mit Lötzinn, dann fließt das viel besser an die Kontakte
und saut auch das Board drumherum nicht ein. Danach kann man es abputzen. Das ist richtig
nice, der Kram. Der Mini Fluxer. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes? Also SSD haben
wir erstmal hier reingepackt. Wunderbar, muss sein. Gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche spannende
Dinge? Jede Menge Amazon-Geschichten, Monitore, brauche ich gar nichts. Falls ich irgendetwas
Spezielles mir angucken soll, Leute, falls ihr da irgendwie, falls es zu irgendetwas mein
Senf geben soll, sag Bescheid, dann kann ich nachgucken. Ansonsten, was haben wir denn
jetzt sonst? Mehr RGB, ganz wichtig. RGB RAM für richtigen FPS Boost. Brauchen wir jetzt
alle für Battlefield 2042? Hetzner hat einen Black Friday Deal. Wie, was ist da los? Warum
hat mir das keiner geschrieben von denen? Da hätten wir doch gleich was machen können.
Ach so, Moment, das ist nicht Hetzner Cloud. Ich habe das Gefühl, die haben da intern so
kleine Rivalität, was Hetzner Cloud und Rätselliche Hetzner Hetzner Sachen angeht. Keine Ahnung,
ob das stimmt. Dein Ausbilder hat dich gezwungen, immer ohne Mini Flux zu löten. Warum? Wollte
der nicht, dass es schön wird oder was? Hast du eigentlich einen Höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch?
Ja. Sind die in Ordnung? Oh, das weiß ich nicht. SSDs muss man sich eigentlich Tests
angucken und gucken, was da für Cellen drin sind. Also hier, Black Friday Week. Da stört
sich doch bestimmt demnächst wieder irgendjemand dran. So, und was ist, wo genau ist hier jetzt
der, ach no, Setup, ah, verstehe. Das heißt, was kostet, was sind denn die normalen Setup
Kosten? Das weiß ich gar nicht. Kosten ist normalerweise Setup. Keine Ahnung. Ich muss
ehrlich sagen, ich habe mir erst einmal einen Hetzner Dedicated Server gekauft und das ist
auch schon zwei Jahre her oder drei oder noch länger. Vier Jahre her. Gib mal deinen Senf
zu Whitescreen-Monitoren. Ich kann da meinen Senf nicht dazu geben, ich habe keinen Whitescreen-Monitor.
Ich habe einen BenQ Monitor, 16 zu 9, 1080p, 240Hz, weil mir 240Hz wichtiger waren, wie
große, also mehr Auflösung und größerer, größerer Bildschirm. Und dementsprechend
kann ich da ehrlich gesagt wenig dazu sagen. Also mir sind FPS gerade was so Sachen wie
Battlefield oder auch allgemein irgendwelches Shooter-Kram angeht, ist mir mehr FPS einfach
wichtiger. Das Hetzner Cloud ist genau genommen eine Unterfirma von Hetzner, okay. Zeig mal,
was kosten hier bei denen? Das ist ja die Server-Auktion. Was kosten bei denen? Wir
gucken jetzt mal was. Ich habe euch ja erzählt, dass wir auf der Arbeit fast 70.000 Euro für
SSDs bezahlt hätten. Und dementsprechend, guck mal mal, was kosten hier SSDs? Guck
mal hier, fette SSDs. Ne, wir suchen Size of Each 3, wir haben hier 2T. Oh, da gibt
es nicht viel. Guck mal, hier würden wir schon, hier würden wir 7TB bekommen, ab 111, na
da wären wir aber deutlich unter 70.000 Euro. Und das ist sogar ein richtig fettes Teil,
Alter. Guck mal hier, das ist ein richtig brutales Ding. 16 Kern Ryzen 5950X, 128G RAM
und 7TB SSD. Alter, das ist, das Ding, das ist schon ordentlich. Achso, ich habe falsches
Land, ne? Ne, fad.de. Passt doch, ich muss nichts abziehen. Achso, du meinst, wenn man
das büsnestechnisch macht, ja dann theoretisch schon. Äh, warte mal, was, was? Ich kriege
gerade komische Dinger geschrieben per PR. Achso, ja. Okay, Call of Duty, Lul, lese
ich nachher. Nice, ja. Äh, da bin ich anderer Meinung. 240Hz hat fast keinen Sinn, weil
es ist schwer überall 240 plus Frames zu bekommen, außer man hat eine. Also, ja, es ist natürlich
nicht easy, dass du in den Games irgendwie mal locker 250Hz machst, aber gerade, wenn
du auch mal ein bisschen ältere Games spielst, so was sagen wir mal wie Battlefield 3, und
das in Low, dann ist das kein Problem. Dann kriegst du das hin. Und ich spiele Games lieber
in Low mit mehr FPS als in hohen Details, Optik und weniger FPS. Ich weiß, dass das
Geschmackssache ist, aber es ist bei mir halt so. Und außerdem, rein theoretisch gesehen,
hat es noch einen weiteren Vorteil, der aber, wie soll ich sagen, wahrscheinlich eher im
Bereich der Theorie messbar ist. Die Chance, dass du auch bei weniger FPS, wenn gerade
ein Bild fertig gerendert ist, der Monitor ready ist zu refreshen, ist natürlich höher.
Das heißt, die Latency wird trotzdem geringer mit 240Hz, auch bei weniger als 240 FPS.
Allerdings bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob man das messen kann, aber in der Theorie ist es
so. Und wenn man G-Sync hat, ist es eh egal. Kennst du den Combi 2-Stick? Ja, den hab
ich am Start. Combi 2-Stick von Decon's Dresden Electronics, ne? Ja, den hab ich. Der ist
gut. Find ich, ist der beste Zigbee-Stick, den man sich so holen kann. Und da steht dir
alles offen. Du kannst die Zigbee-Integration von Home Assistant verwenden, du kannst diese
Decon Zigbee-Geschichte von Dresden Electronics nehmen, oder du nimmst, was mein persönlicher
Favorit ist, Zigbee to MQTT. Das ganze gibt's auch als Home Assistant Addon. Das find ich
persönlich eigentlich am leistesten. Max, lohnt sich Battlefield 2042 jetzt oder lieber
noch 2-3 Monate warten? Also ich glaube, mit 2-3 Monaten ist es da nicht getan. Also wenn
dir das Spiel jetzt überhaupt nicht zusagt, geh ich davon aus, wird dir das Spiel wahrscheinlich
auch in 2-3 Monaten nicht zusagen. Wenn du es an sich ganz cool findest, was du gesehen
hast und einfach nur die aller aller allergröbsten Bugs abwarten willst, dann vielleicht 2-3
Monate. Aber ich glaube, wir werden in nächster Zeit nicht glücklich werden mit diesem Game
leider. Ich find's ja selbst doof, weil ich riesen Battlefield Fanboy bin. Ja gut, das
kann schon sein, aber das ist trotzdem richtig fette Kiste. 5950 X16 Kerne. Selbst wenn das
nicht aktuell ist, ist es immer noch ein ordentliches, fettes Teil. Wie gesagt, mein Monitor hat
1080p 240Hz und ich glaube, 24 Zoll, also es ist entweder 23, 24 oder was kommt denn als
nächstes? 27? Nein, 27 ist es nicht. Also entweder 23, ich glaube 24 Zoll ist ja. Also
wenn du gerne Battlefield 4 gespielt hast, ist Battlefield 2042 wahrscheinlich nicht
das Richtige. Sushi am Samstag? Was? Ne, dann müsste ich ja nach Frankfurt fahren. Rick
James Bitch ist am Start, 2 Monate. Massive Subscription, Dankeschön. Ja. Battlefield
4 Server sind richtig, richtig gut besucht. 24,5 Zoll sind das, ok. Siehst du mal, der
Chat weiß besser, wie groß mein Monitor ist, als ich selbst. Das ist erschreckend mittlerweile
schon. Ach du hast den gleichen. Chat weiß alles, siehst schon. Nein, habe ich mich nicht
mit beschäftigt, aber ich weiß, das erste, was ist das hier wieder für exquisite Musik
im Hintergrund? Ich weiß, was das erste ist, was passieren wird, wenn mal Quantencomputer
für normale Leute erschwinglich sind. Und wisst ihr was das erste ist Leute? Ein Skyrim
Port. Es darf keine Plattform geben ohne Skyrim. Die gibt bestimmt Quantencomputer,
Skyrim Quantenium Edition oder irgendwie sowas. GTA 5 natürlich, GTA 5 darf auch nicht fehlen.
GTA 5 kommt nochmal neu raus. Da machst du dann GTA 5 Roleplay drauf und du hast alle
Entscheidungen auf einmal. Du wirst von der Polizei festgenommen und gleichzeitig nicht.
Hast du noch ein Wallet, wo du das Passwort nicht mehr hast? Wir hatten auch mal einen
etwas länger her schon einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der hat auch immer erzählt, er
hat noch ein Wallet mit 40 Bitcoins, aber der hat viel geschwätzt, wenn der Tag lang
ist. Dem kam ich nicht wirklich geglaubt, aber der hat das so oft erzählt, vielleicht hatte
er einmal wirklich ein Wallet und da war, was weiß ich, 0,4 Bitcoins drin oder so. Weil
wenn da wirklich 40 Bitcoins drin gewesen sind, dann wäre der Typ reich. Ich meine,
was ist aktuell Bitcoin? 60.000 Euro oder so? 70, 50. Okay, es wird ein bisschen runtergegangen
glaube ich. Bisschen, bisschen. Wahrnehm ich mal kurz vor 60, wo ich letztens geguckt
habe. Und stell dir mal vor, der hätte da ein Wallet gehabt mit einfach mal Alter,
mit einfach mal wie viel? 2 Millionen drauf, easy. Easy Money, easy life, ja. Ja, damit
habe ich noch nicht beschäftigt, aber generell muss man ja sagen, Shard 256 ist die beste
Backup-Variante. Weil es ist sehr klein, also wenn du Sachen mit Shard 256 backupsst, dann
brauchst du quasi für Terabyte an Daten bloß ein paar Kilobyte. Der Restore wird halt schwierig.
Aber das ist ungeschlagen in der Größe des Backups. Das hat jetzt glaube ich keiner verstanden
oder? Das war glaube ich zu big und low brain gleichermaßen von mir. Was der Preischampers,
der macht, der läuft noch. YouTube Comments. Okay, Leute bevor wir weitermachen mit den
Black Friday Deals, ich muss mich mal beim Thema auf YouTube auslassen. Und zwar, Zack.
Überleg grad, wo wir da am besten anfangen. Okay, Champ ist weg. Okay, Champ ist weg.
Ja, dann edde ich den mal. Bäm, wieder geedit. Okay, Champ ist da. Dislikes, ich habe auch
mal Leute, ich glaube es ist jetzt übrigens komplett vorbei auf YouTube. Ach guck mal,
hier habe ich noch Dislikes. Bei mir drüben habe ich keine Dislikes mehr auf dem anderen
Account. Hier sind Dislikes weg, bei mir schon. Ich möchte nochmal betonen, was für eine
unglaublich beschissene Idee ich das halte, Dislikes auf YouTube zu entfernen. Aber ich
habe kein eigenes Video zugemacht, aber ich finde das unglaublich bescheuert. Sowas beknacktes,
du kannst bei vielen Videos einfach nicht mehr erkennen, ob die gut oder schlecht sind.
Guckt euch eben den Call of Duty Release Trailer an, hat irgendwie 50.000 Dislikes, 100.000
Likes oder was auch immer und es sieht so aus wie, wow cool kommt der gut an. Die einzigen,
die profitieren sind Trash YouTuber. Die einzigen, die profitieren, behaupte ich mal sogar, sind
weder, egal welche Content Creator, egal ob Trash oder nicht Trash, sondern YouTube. Die
einzigen, die profitieren sind YouTube. YouTube sagt ja, sie machen das mit den Dislikes,
sie machen das mit den Dislikes ja, um Creator zu beschützen oder sowas. Das halte ich persönlich
für totalen Stumpfsinn, das beschützt keine Creator. Das einzige, was das bringt ist,
dass Leute Videos nicht mehr abschalten, die vom Inhalt her schlecht sind, aber so gemacht
sind, dass du sie wirklich gucken würdest, dass du sie trotzdem weiter gucken würdest.
Man kann sich jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob das im Entertainment Bereich dann ein schlechtes
Video ist, aber bei Tutorials ist das auf jeden Fall so. Wenn du ein Tutorial Video guckst,
was quasi so aufgebaut ist, als käme die ganze Zeit noch das, was du wissen willst,
am Ende kommt es nicht, ist das für den YouTube Algorithmus toll, für dich nicht und du willst
einfach auch nicht jedes Mal 1-2 Stunden Konferenztalks durchklicken, um zu wissen, was denn da eigentlich
Sache ist und du hast gerade Konferenztalks, Tutorialvideos, hast du sie wunderbar erkannt
mit Dislikes, ob das sich lohnt anzuschauen oder nicht und das ist einfach weg. Das ist
Scheiße auf YouTube, das finde ich richtig kacke. Und das beschützt keine Content Creator
am Ende. Wisst ihr, was es am Ende bringt? So wie alles übrigens. Es bringt Stonks und
Geld für YouTube. Das ist auch alles, was YouTube interessiert. Man darf sich da nichts
vormachen, dass YouTube das irgendwie machen würde, um kleine Content Creator vor dem großen
Shitstorm-Hatred zu bewahren. Das ist kompletter Blödsinn. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das
gar nicht vorkommt, dass irgendwie Dislike-Bots am Start sind oder sowas. Einmal mal ganz
ehrlich, eine Interaction auf YouTube ist auch eine Interaction, also eine Dislike-Interaction,
was wahrscheinlich sogar noch vorteilhaft ist für das Video und außerdem könnte der
Creator das immer noch ausschalten und ich behaupte einfach mal, die vereinzelten Fälle,
wo das vorkommt, ich will ja gar nicht bestreiten, dass es vorkommt, aber die vereinzelten Fälle,
wo das passiert, dass jemand wirklich gedislike-bottet wird oder sowas, rechtfertigen es nicht,
dieses Feature für die gesamte Plattform zu deaktivieren. Da muss man sich was anderes
überlegen. Ja, das wird passieren. Genau das wird passieren, Leute. Genau das, was hier
der Chat schreibt. New Metabit, like this comment if you disliked this video. Exakt,
das wird passieren. Und Leute, ich hatte eine mega geile, nicht Startup, Startup ist das
falsche Ding. Ich gründe deswegen bestimmt keine zweite Firma oder so. Ich hatte eine
richtig gute Service-Idee. DislikeButton.services, wir machen eine Domain, da kann man Videos
disliken. Da kann man YouTube-Videos disliken, also ein externer Service, der nur dafür da
ist, YouTube-Videos zu disliken. Quasi ein global Dislike-Button. Zu kompliziert, warum?
Wenn du einen Comment machst, wenn du einen Comment machst, so nach dem Motto, hier geht's
zu den Dislikes, DislikeChamp zum Beispiel, klappt das. Und du könntest ja sogar, du
könntest sogar eine Browser-Extension anbieten. Also die Idee finde ich eigentlich gar nicht
mal so kacke. Ja, das funktioniert nicht. Das funktioniert nicht. Weißt du, warum das
nicht funktioniert? Weil die meisten Leute mobile gucken und nicht auf dem Desktop.
Nee, nee, ich mache nichts mit Hate. Das ist zu negativ vorbelastet. Und soll ich euch
mal was sagen, Leute? Ich habe sogar schon angefangen, ein bisschen was zu basteln, habe
mir eine Domain registriert. Und wisst ihr, was für eine Big-Prain-Fivehead-Domain ich
mir ergattern konnte für diese Geschichte? Dislike.Cloud. Also ein besserer Name für
diesen Service kann es nicht geben. DislikeCloud. Warum auch immer das Parkt, ich habe mir den
Programm gekauft. Dislike as a Service, genau. War das teuer? Ja, 20 Euro, teurer als meine
anderen Domains. Dislike, ich wollte ja erst Dislike.me, wollte ich erst kaufen. Die kostet
aber, passt mal auf. Die haben sich irgendwelche Seller gekauft und die ist Premium und manch
andere kannst du für 2000 Euro kaufen, das war jetzt bescheuert. Also vorbei, auf die
Ideen sind schon andere gekommen. Okay Leute, jetzt lasse ich mich mal über aktuelle YouTube-Sachen
aus, wozu ich einfach mal was sagen will. Ich suche euch mal das Comment raus, mal gucken,
ob ich das finde. Ansonsten habe ich auch einen Screenshot von dem Comment hier. Ich suche
ein Comment von BenBit, wozu ich einfach mal was sagen wollte. Ich glaube, das ist hier
drunter. Schauen wir mal, ich gucke mal, wenn ich es nicht finde, zeige ich euch den Screenshot
vom Kommentar. Ach ne, nicht hier, in dem neuesten Video ist das drunter. Wer das neuste
Video von mir durchgeguckt hat, in your face, anklicken, gucken. Was auch immer in your
face, kein Schimmer. Einfach so. Wir suchen ein Video von BenBit. Alter, diese YouTube-Suche,
ich weiß, dass es das Comment gibt. Ich habe darauf geantwortet und gescreenshotted vorhin.
Ich kann auch YouTube-Kommentare durchsuchen über das YouTube-Studio. Aber das ist ja
fail. Warum findet ihr das nimmer? Okay, Quaint, ich zeige euch einfach den Screenshot vom
Kommentar. Warum auch immer der das nicht findet, das ist ja schon mal richtig. Also
diese YouTube-Geschichte ist wirklich richtiger fail. Aber hier ist es doch. Also, okay. Ich
überlege gerade, wo ich da am besten anfange. Also, es gibt ein paar Dinge, es gab ein paar
Kommentare im letzten Video und es gab ein paar Kommentare jetzt hier unter dem Video,
wo ich einfach mir gedacht habe, ich muss da mal ein paar Dinge zu ansprechen. Ist schon
im Spam? Nee, nee, ist nicht im Spam. Ist nicht im Spam. Wo ich was zu ansprechen musste.
Und er schreibt hier, das ist ein Comment, wo es viele in dieser Richtung, mal kurz die
Musik vielleicht einen Ticken leiser. Oder eben ein bisschen entspannenderes. Irgendwie
so. Oh, jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht. Okay, lassen wir es jetzt einfach mal so. YouTube.
Nein, müssen wir nicht. Wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Hier. Hat wer eine Empfehlung für
die Laptop-Marke, die man gut auseinanderbauen kann? Ja, ich habe letztens irgend so ein Projekt
gesehen, was das als Ziel hatte, aber kriege ich gerade nicht mal zusammen. Also, kommen
wir mal zu dieser YouTube-Geschichte. Es gab relativ viele Comments auch in dieser Richtung,
auch welche, die das angesprochen haben, was ich sagen wollte. Aber ich dachte mir, ich
musste einfach mal was zu sagen, weil ich glaube, vielen Leuten ist das nicht ganz
klar. Und zwar, er schreibt hier sowas wie, glaube nicht, dass DICE jemals ein Fehler
eingestehen wird. Auf Twitter feiern sich die Devs für ihren tollen Release ab und
für das ganze Battlefield-5-Debakel haben sich auch nicht entschuldigt. Also, gut, ob
man sich jetzt über Battlefield-5 entschuldigen muss oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber
ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so ist. Kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen. Ich folge keinen
DICE-Entwicklern auf Twitter. Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich abfeiern oder ob das eher die
Marketing-Stonks-Leute sind, die der Meinung sind, beste Spiel aller Zeiten, was wir da
released haben. Kein Schimmer. Also, quasi Leute, die alles hypen gegen Monatsgehälter,
was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist. Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wisst ihr, wer
auch transchuld ist, und das ist das, worauf ich raus will, wo mich aber dieses Comment
quasi zugebracht hat. Ich dachte mir, da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen. Wisst ihr, wer
da auch mit transchuld ist, dass dieses ganze Gehype und dass das Spiel in dem Zustand ist,
wie es jetzt ist. Ich sage nicht, die Hauptsächliche schuldigt aber mit, die Schuld dran hat, und
das sind Content-Creator. Aber anders, als ihr denkt. Nein, das sind auch nicht alles
Hater, aber Content-Creator sind mit transchuld. Aber anders, als ihr jetzt vielleicht denken
mögt. Ich hatte ja bei Battlefield 2042 ein bisschen Einblick in den Ablauf. Ich war
bei ein paar Events eingeladen. Ein Einblick in die Kommunikation, wie das auf solchen
Events läuft. Ich meine, ich habe für die offiziellen Sachen in der NDA unterschrieben,
die sind zwar auch schon abgelaufen, aber ich will jetzt trotzdem hier keine Namen reinhauen
oder sagen, wer da wem was geschrieben hat. Aber ich sage nichts Konkretes, aber ich war
bei den Events dabei und ich war auch in dem Discord zu den Events und eine Sache ist mir
da halt aufgefallen. Und die ist echt richtig extrem. Gerade bei solchen Events. Und ich
habe es in der Form auch, also so krass wie bei DICE habe ich das auch noch nicht erlebt.
Und zwar, die Leute schleimen extremst rum. Es ist echter Wahnsinn. Die schleimen wirklich
rum, als gibt es kein Morgen mehr. Im Preview Event hatten sie glaube ich, also im Preview
Event, wo man Battlefield 2042 im Vorfeld spielen konnte, hatten sie glaube ich die
Wettereffekte raufgestellt. Mit das halt oft kommt. Und der Discord ist eskaliert. Nicht
irgendwie negativ, so nach dem Motto, das Wetter geht uns auf den Keks oder sowas. Und
ich rede jetzt hauptsächlich von den englischsprachigen Creators. Die sind so ausgeflippt über jede
Kleinigkeit und haben DICE so wirklich das Gefühl gegeben, sie haben das Rad neu erfunden.
Das war absoluter Wahnsinn. Es war Dauergeschleime pur. Die sind komplett ausgeflippt. Und man
hat auch gemerkt, dass die DICE Leute richtig happy gewesen sind. Ich meine, wenn man sich
quasi als Entwickler oder als Studio in dem Fall, als Designer, was auch immer, wenn du
dich quasi die ganze Zeit in so einem Entwicklungsprozess nur mit solchen Leuten umgibst, dann glaubst
du es glaube ich wirklich irgendwann. Dabei ist dieses Geschleime ja hauptsächlich selbstzweck.
Muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen. Warum schleimen die rum? Auch wenn ihnen was nicht gefällt,
natürlich. Wer früher Infos hat und früher Content bringen darf, gewinnt halt im Endeffekt.
Gewinnt mag jetzt vielleicht das harte Wort sein, aber ihr wisst was ich meine. Und ich
habe in Chat geschrieben, zum Beispiel, ich rede übrigens hauptsächlich von englischsprachigen
Content Creator, nicht von deutschsprachigen, aber ich habe bei uns, auch bei diesem Event
in Chat geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, das Wetter ist mir fast schon ein bisschen viel.
Aber ihr wisst, ich mecke aber sowas immer ganz gerne rum und ich sage das auch, wenn
mir was nicht gefällt. Das ist halt meine Einschätzung. Ich denke mir halt, wenn man
Sachen nicht anspricht, die nerven, dann ändert es auch keiner. Aber ich finde das fragwürdig,
dass die alle so krass mit Samthandschuhen immer angefasst werden. So nach dem Motto,
auch bei solchen, wenn man sich die Kritikvideos da teilweise anguckt, meine Güte, wie gesagt,
ich rede hauptsächlich von der englischsprachigen Battlefield Creator Szene. Da wird erstmal
5 Minuten, wir haben uns letztens so ein Video zusammen angeguckt hier im Stream, da wird
erstmal 5 Minuten rumgeschleimt und gesagt, wie great und toll das alles ist und dass
das Game eigentlich ja ganz gut ist und so als wäre das alles ein Versehen, dass das
Game doch nicht so geil ist und die Leute müssen erstmal einen 5 Minuten Intro machen,
in dem sie krass rumschleimen, um die Zuschauer und irgendwie Dice oder wer auch immer da
guckt seelisch und moralisch darauf vorzubereiten, dass gleich ein wenig Kritik kommt. Wisst
ihr so nach dem Motto, als würde jetzt der Kopf der Leute explodieren, wenn sie direkt
Kritik hören, ohne 5 Minuten erstmal darauf vorbereitet zu werden, dass gleich ein wenig
Kritik kommt. Und ich denke mir auch, viel weichgewaschener geht das einfach nicht mehr,
was da viele englischsprachige Content Creator abziehen. Also das hat mich wirklich auf diesem
Event echt mal wieder, da hat mich die Realität wieder eingeholt. Ich dachte, die Leute sagen
halt auch mal was nicht gut ist, geben ein bisschen Feedback, aber die geben kein Feedback,
die Entwickler sagen ja sogar explizit, gebt uns bitte Feedback, ich mach das eigentlich
in der Regel auch, ja, gebt uns bitte Feedback, aber das einzige Feedback, was man bekommt
ist, dass krass rumgeschleimt wird, dass es das geilste Spiel auf der Welt ist. Das habe
ich auch bei Battlefield 1 schon gesehen, das war auch schlimm, da habe ich vor Ort
live mitgekriegt, meine Güte wurde rumgeschleimt und jetzt wieder bei Battlefield 2042. Auch
bei anderen Games, aber gerade die Kombination englischsprachige Content Creator und Dice
scheint mir so ein echt so Goldgrube zu sein, was rumgeschleimt angeht. Ich habe fast das
Gefühl, die stecken alle schon ein bisschen zu weit, alle unter einer Decke. Ja, das
muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen. Und kein Wunder, dass Dice dann denkt, sie haben das
beste Spiel seit der Erfindung des Rats irgendwie gebaut. Das wundert mich nicht, wenn du nur
Leute hast, die dir die ganze Zeit erzählen, dass es das geilste auf der Welt ist und sie
noch nie in ihrem Leben sowas Geiles gespielt haben und ja, das ist toll, alles toll und
sonst wie, also was denkt man denn da als Entwickler? Ja, das ist das geilste, was es
gibt. Die müssten sich in Wirklichkeit Leute holen, die in anderen vielleicht ähnlich
gelagerten Spielen gut sind. Das müssen weder Content Creator noch Streamer noch sonst was
sein. Die könnten sich die ein oder andere, die sollen sich vielleicht mal Pros holen
von anderen Games, fragen, kannst du das mal ausprobieren? Was ist dein Feedback dazu?
Oder eben halt auch eingesessene Battlefield Fans, die ja mal auch den Mund aufmachen
und wirklich ein realistisches Feedback schreiben. Weil von den englischsprachigen Content Creator
kriegst du das aus meiner Sicht selten. Und ob es von den deutschsprachigen ist, kann
ich schlecht einschätzen. Da ist mir aber nichts, nichts negativ aufgefallen. Aber das
fand ich echt diesmal wieder ganz, ganz extrem. Ja. Ich mein, vermutlich ist es bei Spielezeitschriften
auch nicht besser. Oder wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist es da ähnlich. Wer nichts Gutes schreibt,
wird halt nicht eingeladen. Lände mal den Chat ein. Wer nichts Gutes schreibt oder wer
zu negativ ist, wird halt nicht eingeladen. Man darf nicht vergessen, so Informationen
sind halt in diesem Business letztendlich Views und damit bares Geld. Und wir hatten mal einen
Kollege auf der Arbeit, den mochte ich echt, ich will ihn erzählen. Ich will nicht sagen,
dass es irgendwie schlecht war oder so. Aber er kam aus Russland und war mega höflich,
also richtig, richtig krass höflich. Richtig so. Und der hat auch nie gesagt, wenn man Mist
gebaut hat oder wenn man gerade Mist macht, der hat dann immer nur so von der Seite angeschaut.
Und wenn ich dann, ich hab dann getippt und getippt und hab eigentlich total Mist getippt
und er schaut mich halt die ganze Zeit so von der Seite an. Und bis man sich dann zu ihm
umgedreht hat, hat ihn dann gefragt, ich nenne ihn jetzt einfach mal Boris, Boris Kekomret.
Hab ich einfach gesagt, was gibt es denn, was ist denn? Und dann hat er das ultra vorsichtig
ausgedrückt. Dann hat er sowas gesagt wie, ja Max, man könnte das, was du machst auch
vielleicht anders machen. So, in seiner Sprache, in seiner Logik, hieß das übersetzt, Max,
das was du da gerade machst, ist der übelste Schrott. Und das ist der letzte Müll, was
du da gerade gemacht hast. Aber der hat das so mega vorsichtig und zuvorkommend ausgedrückt.
Und circa so ist, zumindest im englischsprachigen Raum, die Kritik der meisten Content-Creator
wären diesen Briefview-Events gewesen. Ich glaube, das kann man damit eigentlich ganz
gut umschreiben. Dazu kommt natürlich auch, fällt mir jetzt auch gerade noch ein, dazu
kommt natürlich auch, dass es, sagen wir so das Hypen und Extreme besser ankommen wie
realistisch sein. Also wenn dann einer eine Video macht, oh my god, new battlefield looks
fucking amazing oder sick oder was auch immer, so irgendwas richtig krasses reinschreibt,
da kommst du natürlich weiter, wie wenn man sagt, naja, also bisher hat man eigentlich
kaum was gesehen, das was man bis jetzt gesehen hat, ist eigentlich ganz okay. Oder, oder,
man haut direkt voll rein und sagt so nach dem new battlefield game looks like trash
oder irgendwie sowas. Und mit diesen Extremen kannst du da reinhauen, aber mit so realistischen
Sachen, finde ich, scheint es nicht so zu klappen. Deswegen, guckt euch die Titel durch
am Anfang, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo es diese Technik-Demo zu Battlefield gab,
wo man diese Soldaten übers Schlachtfeld hat laufen sehen, die haben sich überschlagen
im englischsprachigen YouTube, die haben sich komplett überlagen, new battlefield tech
looks better than ever oder so Zeug, die sind voll eskaliert, man hat nichts gesehen, man
hat schwarz-weiß gesehen, Moment, ich zeige euch mal kurz, was ich meine. Battlefield,
war das tech, Demo, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der Gramm hieß. Das hier, nein, nein.
Das hier. Als man das das erste Mal gesehen hat, und in dem Fall bei dem Video ist tatsächlich
Jack-Flag über der grümliche Ausnahme, als man das hier gesehen hat, das war ja eigentlich
fast nichts, man hat fast nichts gesehen und die sind alle ausgeflippt. Wie gesagt, als
hätte DICE das Rad neu erfunden, unglaublich. Ja, da kann man schon mal ausrasten, ja. Und
ich finde, die GameStar macht es eigentlich ganz gut. Fällt mir jetzt gerade so ein. Ich
finde, die GameStar macht das eigentlich ganz gut. GameStar sind ja nicht klassische Battlefield-Content-Creator
oder so, aber ich finde, die GameStar macht das eigentlich relativ gut. Die sind meistens
ziemlich objektiv, so objektiv man halt bei Games sein kann. Wirklich objektiv geht das
kaum. Ich meine, man kann Games ja nicht abharten nach einfachen Checklisten, man kann nicht
sagen, Grafik-Check, Sound-Check, Movement-Check und das gibt dann 85%. Das geht ja bei Games
nicht, also das ist immer recht individuell, wie man Games bewerten muss. Aber ich finde
trotzdem, die GameStar ist in dem Bereich immer noch das Beste, was wir haben. Ich kann sicherlich
über viele Sachen sich streiten bei der GameStar. Ich lese da auch bei weitem nicht alles, nur
mal so selektiv. Ich hatte lange Zeit ein GameStar-Abo, habe ich auch schon lange gekündigt,
aber ich finde immer noch, GameStar ist in der Richtung das Beste, was wir haben. Und
die GameStar macht auch auf ihrem YouTube-Channel immer so kritische objektive Videos. Also
ich finde, die machen das wirklich gut und leider ist mittlerweile vieles spannender,
immer, immer plus Artikel, was du gar nicht lesen kannst. Und wie gesagt, ich habe sogar
hier oben noch eine GameStar-CD-Ligen von, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich jetzt da drauf
komme, aber ich habe noch eine GameStar-CD-Ligen hier von 1998 mit irgendeiner Incoming-Vollversion,
ist das glaube ich. Und das war richtig cringe, Alter. Weiß nicht, ob das noch jemand kennt
von früher, Raumschiff GameStar war da drauf. Hyper cringe, falls das noch jemand kennt.
Also Raumschiff GameStar ist wirklich so eines der cringiesten Dinger, die man sich angucken
kann, aber ich habe es trotzdem gefeiert damals. Fall of Seven, ja das kenne ich, das kenne
ich. Streamprojekt plus Artikel DShip 4, ich glaube die liefern plus Artikel einfach,
das kenne ich gar nicht aus. Ich lese übrigens gleich die Sachen im Chat. Muss erstmal alles
los werden, aber ich glaube, ich bin soweit, alles los geworden zu diesem Thema. Ja, ich
weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt auf die GameStar gekommen bin, keine Ahnung. Aber ich war
davor glaube ich bei Content Creator, ne? Letztendlich dürfen wir auch einen Punkt nicht vergessen
und der ist auch wichtig. Content Creators und Streamer entscheiden am Ende mit darüber,
was populär wird und was nicht. Ich meine nicht immer, aber oft. Die ganze Sus-Geschichte
wäre ohne Twitch nie im Leben so groß geworden. Ich meine bevor Twitch Among Us abgepickt
hat, hatte das irgendwie 20 Spieler oder so. Kaum hat Twitch das gemacht, ging es mit Sus
und Zeug los und wir können ja mal, wir machen mal was, ich habe eine Idee. Steam-Stats,
wir gucken jetzt mal, was die Top-Spiele auf Steam sind und welche davon beliebt sind
auf Twitch. Ich würde sagen, ich sage es sind nicht alle, aber ein großer Teil ist
es. Okay, Track What's Played, zeig mal her. CS, das ist so, das ist bei Events, also bei
Events ist das auf Twitch relativ nice, aber es gibt auch sonst genug CS-Streamer, aber
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass CS so richtig, richtig big ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
groß, dadurch, dass das Spiel beliebt ist, auch auf Twitch. Dota 2 ist auch relativ gut
vorne mit dabei, aber jetzt auch nicht hier neue Rekorde. New World, gut, das ist so ein
Übergangsding, ich gehe davon aus, dass New World demnächst in der Bedeutungslosigkeit
versinkt, genauso wie die Spielerzahlen. Das wird ähnlich gehen mit den Twitch-Views.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es jetzt aussieht. Twitch, New World. Ah, siehst du, ist schon,
ist schon mehr oder weniger, gut 17.000 Zuschauer, aber immer noch ganz, ganz okay, aber es ist
schon bei weitem nicht mehr so weit oben, wie man sich das vorstellt. Okay, ich habe
bei den deutschen Creator angeguckt, 5.000, also ist immer noch ganz gut dabei, aber wie
gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass es auch demnächst in der Bedeutungslosigkeit versinkt. Halo
Infinite, frisch rausgekommen. Halo war nie der super beliebte Titel auf Twitch, ich könnte
mir auch vorstellen, dass es in Zukunft vielleicht ein bisschen aufwärts geht, aber ich denke
nicht, dass Halo auf Twitch jetzt das riesengroße Ding werden wird, also ich glaube nicht, dass
Halo Infinite jetzt irgendwie das neue Twitch-Meta wird, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also
wäre es auf jeden Fall so ein Ding, wo ich sagen würde, ja, ist auf Twitch präsent,
aber jetzt nicht so krass und ist trotzdem beliebt und wird hoffentlich auch eine Weile
bleiben. Apex auf jeden Fall, dick auf Twitch dabei. Puppke, nicht mehr so, aber war mal
quasi Twitch-Meta Nummer 1. Team Fortress, ja, hier haben wir das erste Game, was keine
Scheiße ausstreamt. Sag ich jetzt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich guck mal. Warte mal,
ich guck mal, aber ich glaube nicht. Twitch, Team Fortress 2. Nee. 455 Viewer. Also Team
Fortress 2 anscheinend beliebt, aber streamt wirklich niemand. Also das ist eine der Ausnahmen
hier. Farming Simulator, keine Ahnung, ob das ein großes Ding auf Twitch ist, kein Schimmer.
Rust ist auf jeden Fall auf Twitch zeitweise sehr beliebt. Also ich finde, man sieht schon
den Zusammenhang, oder GTA, GTA ist natürlich, also GTA ist ja gefühlt mehr Leute auf Twitch
als Leute, die es spielen. Ich meine, es ist wahnsinnig beliebt, keine Frage, aber GTA
ist ja riesengroß mittlerweile auch auf Twitch. Also ich finde, man sieht hier schon, dass
viele der Top-Games auch die Games sind, die auf Twitch angesagt sind. Ich meine, klar,
da kommt das eine zum anderen. Streamer streamen gerne beliebte Games und natürlich sind die
Gaming-Hersteller auch darauf bedacht, dass ihr Game dementsprechend gut platziert ist
auf Twitch. Und denen ist auch klar, dass der Erfolg eines Games heutzutage mit daran
hängt, wie gut das auf Twitch und wie gut das natürlich auch auf YouTube ankommt. Das
wissen die ja, aber es ist nicht bei jedem Game so. Wie gesagt, Among Us hat vor Twitch
kein Mensch gespielt und ich glaube, jetzt können wir mal kurz gucken. Ich bin mir gar
nicht so sicher, wie das jetzt aussieht. Ja, ich würde sagen, der große Hype ist vorbei
und es ist in halbwegs normalen Gefilden wieder. GTA hat 400.000 Zuschauer, ja. Also es gucken
mehr Leute zu. Gut, da ist Montana Black auch ganz vorne hier mit dabei, auch international,
aber es gucken mehr Leute zu, als Leute GTA spielen gerade. Das muss man sich erstmal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, wenn man sich das Ganze anguckt hier. Wobei ich nicht weiß,
vielleicht weiß das einer von euch, ich kenne mich damit nicht aus, ob diese Roleplay-Server
hier bei Steam auftauchen, keine Ahnung. Aber wahrscheinlich, weil es über Steam gestartet
wird. Davon sind sicherlich auch einige Social Club und Epic, klar. Aber ich denke trotzdem,
jetzt weiß ich auch wieder, worauf ich raus wollte, aber ich denke trotzdem, dass die Hersteller
ihre Fans im Auge behalten sollten, also den Kern. Wie gesagt, Content-Creator sind oftmals
auch schnell wieder weg, wenn der Twitch-Hype abflaut und quasi das nur darauf auszulegen
jetzt irgendwie, dass ein Game besonders streamerfreundlich oder so ist sicherlich auch nicht der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss. Ich habe jetzt ja ein bisschen Halo gespielt und ich muss sagen, also Halo Infinite,
Multiplayer, das hat mir richtig Spaß gemacht, aber eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen, also
als ich Offstream ein bisschen Halo gespielt habe. Und da habe ich mir so im Kopf gedacht,
ok, aus irgendwelchen Gründen bin ich auf diese Idee gekommen, ihr könnt mir ja mal
in den Chat schreiben, ob ihr der Meinung seid, da ist was dran. Ich habe mir so gedacht,
sowohl Battlefield als auch Halo haben früher quasi so die Trends mitgesetzt, ja vor Battlefield
gab es sowas in der Richtung nicht und vor Halo gab es auch sowas in der Richtung nicht
und die haben quasi Trends gesetzt früher und haben das ganze so für Jahre hinaus mitdefiniert
und heute rennen beide ein bisschen den aktuellen Trends hinterher, so von Service-Model, Skins,
Season Pairs, ich meine ok, bei Battlefield ist das ganze aktuell noch ein bisschen lächerlicher
im Ingame Store ist nicht mal was drinnen. Also du machst in Battlefield aktuell den
Ingame Store auf und es ist einfach leer. Da denke ich mir auch, was ist das für eine
Logik, da sieht man mal, also wenn sogar schon der Ingame Store unfertig ist, dann sagt
glaube ich alles über das Game. Bei Halo gibt es wenigstens richtig coole Sachen. Ach
da sind jetzt zwei Sachen drin, ja also als ich bei Release geguckt habe, war da noch
nix drinne. Ja man könnte das auch positiv deuten, aber ich glaube das liegt nicht daran,
dass sie uns nichts verkaufen wollen, sondern es einfach schlicht ergreifend, also ein Battle
Pass. Für was genau sollte ich aktuell den Battle Pass kaufen in Battlefield 2042? Also
hat das irgendwelche Vorteile den Battle Pass zu kaufen? Also ich überlege mir gerade,
was mache ich mit dem Battle Pass, außer hoffen, dass sie ungefähr das machen, was sie angekündigt
haben, dass irgendwann die erste Season startet Anfang des nächsten Jahres, wo man nicht
genau weiß, was sie genau machen wollen, was genau reinkommt und sonst was. Aber da
kann ich mir noch den Season Pass auch kaufen, wenn es dann soweit ist. Oder sehe ich das
jetzt falsch? Verstehe ich nicht. Naja zumindest bei Halo gibt es auf jeden Fall coole Sachen
im In-Game im Season Pass. Also im In-Game Shop kann man sich Credits kaufen und dann
den Season Pass. Aber im Season Pass gibt es bei Halo wenigstens wirklich richtig coole
Sachen. Von neuen Kampfanzügen, ich hab den Halo Speak nicht so drauf, von neuen Anzügen
bis dann hast du irgendwelche coolen Intro Animationen und hast AI Dinger, Sticker,
Voice Packs und alles. Natürlich ist das letztendlich alles um den Leuten das Geld
aus der Tasche zu ziehen, aber wenn man den Leuten schon das Geld aus der Tasche zieht,
dann kann man es wenigstens mit coolen Inhalten machen und ich finde, dass das was man sieht,
ich meine Halo ist zwar nicht wirklich Early Access, kann man nicht sagen, die sind ja
quasi gelauncht, aber das Spiel an sich ist ja noch nicht voll raus. Also ich glaube,
das ist zumindest schon mal ein guter Hinweis für in welche Richtung das bei Halo Infinite
geht und zumindest hat Halo im Vergleich zu Battlefield aktuell wenigstens coole Sachen
zu bieten was Cosmetics angeht und wirkt auch deutlich mehr Polished. Aber trotzdem irgendwie
hatte ich so diesen Gedanke letztens, dass sowohl Battlefield als auch Halo früher halt
die Sachen mit definiert haben und Trends gesetzt haben und heute müssten sie quasi
aufholen zu den neueren Sachen. So schnell kann sich das ändern, das hat man sich früher
auch nicht gedacht und ich meine, die hatten ja für Battlefield 2042 noch nicht mal Budget
für Musik, wie es aussieht. Es ginge anscheinend alles für Werbung drauf. Habt ihr euch mal
das Battlefield 2042 Main Theme angehört? Passt mal auf, wahrscheinlich haben das die meisten
nicht gemacht, weil sie nicht wussten, dass das das Main Theme ist. Passt mal auf, Battlefield
2042 Main Theme. Ihr lacht euch kaputt, ihr lacht euch kaputt. Man findet das noch nicht
mal. Äh, Zack, ich hab irgendwo nen Bookmark dazu. Das hatte ich mir eben schon mal aufgeschrieben.
Warte mal, ich hab irgendwo nen Bookmark dazu. Ja, hier ist es. Ist Battlefield 2042
Dynamite ein Drecksgame? Also wenn du das so drastisch ausdrücken willst und wenn wir
uns mal den aktuellen Zustand angucken, dann würde ich sagen, es geht definitiv in die
Richtung eines Drecksgames. Ne, das ist nicht der offizielle Channel hier, das ist das offizielle
Main Theme von Battlefield 2042. Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus. Äh, hier,
hört euch das mal an. Da war kein Budget mehr übrig. Alter, was ist das? Das hat
alles ein 5-Jähriger gemacht. Ey, das hört sich an, als ist einer auf dem Klo am Kacken
und ist da irgendwie, und du nimmst das durch die Tür auf. Was ist das? Ich mein, the fuck?
Ey, dann hätt ich mir lieber, dann hätt ich mir lieber jedes Mal den Ubisoft, äh, Flötentyp
angehört. Ne, äh, wo ist der? Gamescom Flut, ne, E3 war das. Ja, dann hätt ich mir
lieber den Typ jedes Mal angehört. Ja, das wär mir lieber als das komische Zeug. Guck
mal hier, der geht richtig ab mit seiner Flöte. Das ist ja fast schon mehr Battlefield als
offizielle Battlefield. Der will's richtig wissen. Der kann's wenigstens, ja. Der kann's
wenigstens. So, und jetzt im Vergleich, wir spulen jetzt mal ein bisschen vor, weil das
Ganze geht ja zwei Minuten dreißig. Die hätten noch nicht mal Hans Zimmer buchen müssen.
Die hatten, Leute, Battlefield 1 hatte zum Beispiel sogar Battlefield 1 Menü Music.
Die hatten was richtig Gutes. Ne, Battlefield 1? Ja, ich glaub, das ist das Richtige. Hier.
Das ist doch nice. Das, das hört sich, das hört sich wenigstens gut an. Das hört sich
richtig gut an. Und jetzt, jetzt spulen wir hier mal ein bisschen vor. Alter, dieser Kontrast,
Mann. Hier, Leute am Start, die Plan haben, was sie machen. Okay, das will ich dem, dem
Komponist nicht mal unterstellen, weil das war, der hat das nach Auftrag gemacht. Aber
hier, wo es irgendwie eine Vision gibt. Das ist einfach, einfach gut gemacht. Du, du wusstest,
hey, der Typ, der das komponiert hat, ist Big Brain. Das Orchester ist Big Brain. Das
Spiel hat eine Vision. Auch wenn es nicht mein Lieblingsbattlefield war, ganz und gar
nicht. So, das ist nice. Und jetzt, Achtung. Aber wir spulen mal ein bisschen vor. Alter,
es hört sich an, als ist irgendwie eine Schallplatte, die Nadel kaputt. Was ist das, Mann? Haben
die das den Fiverr in Auftrag gegeben, oder was? Na gut, egal. Es ist Müll, um so viel
dazu zu sagen. Und ich finde, daran sieht man einfach, ey, wenn die Musik schon, wenn
schon anscheinend kein Budget für ordentliche Musik vorhanden war, obwohl die EA im Rücken
haben und genug Cola haben, ist ja kein Problem. Also, an Budget hat es ja nicht wirklich gescheitert.
Die haben ja auch was, die haben ja auch, ich dachte, ich dachte, der Flöten-Typ läuft
noch. Die haben ja auch tausende Leute irgendwie draufgeschmissen oder so, oder hunderte, ich
weiß nicht, wie viele es wirklich waren. Aber das kann doch nicht sein. Das ist einfach
nur Rauschen von der Musik her. Oh, Mann. Egal. Aber jetzt kommen wir mal zu einem anderen
Comment, wo ich was sagen wollte. Und zwar, wo haben wir es denn hier? Wo ist denn hier
der Jens Spahn-Typ? Wo habe ich denn hin, dass ich so schlimm wie Jens Spahn bin, Mann?
Nein, nein, nein, das gucken wir jetzt nicht. Zu viele Köche verderben den Brei, ja, das
habe ich lustigerweise auch im Vorfeld gesagt schon, dass ich das ein bisschen kritisch
sehe. So, kommen wir mal zu diesem Comment hier. Da wollte ich nämlich auch mal was sagen
und jetzt, wo ich ein bisschen über Content-Creator hergezogen habe, muss ich auch nochmal was
anderes sagen, weil es ging ja viel her, so nach viel darüber her, alle Content-Creator
sind gekauft. Ich würde natürlich nie sowas machen. Wo ist es denn? Hier, also das Comment,
also das da nicht, die Antwort, die Antwort meine ich jetzt, um die es geht. Also, ich
habe jetzt ja, ich habe ein bisschen hergezogen über Content-Creator allgemein, vor allem
die Englischsprachigen. Okay, also wo fange ich denn da jetzt am besten an? Ich muss jetzt
mal auch die Content-Creator gleichermaßen auch mal ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen, weil
es gibt viele solcher Comments. Ein Charlatan, das ist auch so richtig krasse Oldschool-Belleidigung.
Naja, zumindest, ich muss jetzt die Content-Creator mal ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen. Es gab
einige Comments so nach dem Motto, es hat auch einer geschrieben, sinngemäß, toll
Max, jetzt bist du schuld daran, dass die nie wieder dieses Gameguns machen, dass die
nie dieses Game fixen, weil du redest das Game ja so schlecht, die stellen das Game jetzt
ein und wir bekommen nie was. Danke Max. So, sinngemäß hat der Comment geschrieben. Müssen
wir beim Discord raussuchen dieses Comment. Richtig bescheuert, also ich meine ganz, okay,
es ist, es ist ein Funken, ein Funken Wahrheit ist natürlich dann bei solchen Comments dabei.
Also von dem, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe, Funken Wahrheit ist natürlich dabei, aber
wo hat das Problem denn seinen Ursprung? Dort, wo das Game quasi in, also wer das Game
in diesen miesen Zustand gebracht hat oder wo das Game in diesem miesen Zustand rausgekommen
ist oder die, die jetzt darüber reden? Also sprich, die Leute sollen auf EA und Dice
sauer sein, aber doch nicht auch quasi den Überbringer der schlechten Nachrichten. Das
ist wie wenn man im Mittelalter den Boote erschossen hat. Die können da noch nichts
dafür. So, und jetzt mal zu dieser Sponsortgeschichte. Da hat sich nicht nur er aufgeregt, da haben
sich einige aufgeregt und das hier fand ich jetzt halt besonders geil, weil er mich jetzt
mit Spahn vergleicht, okay. Ich hätte auch gerne so ein nicees Haus wie der, aber das
ist irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, etwas am, weiß ich nicht, ich verstehe die Logik
nicht so ganz. Ich mein, offensichtlich ist er war richtig sauer. So viel, so viel ist
da schon mal sicher, dass er ziemlich angepisst war. Und es gab auch viele, die meinten, so
Max, wie kannst du die sponsoren lassen bei einem Game, das dir nicht gefällt? Und ja,
er hat dann irgendwie auch hier das Zeug geschrieben, hat sich aufgeregt und also ja,
als erstes muss man sagen, der hat die Frage nicht richtig verstanden. Das ist richtig,
weil es ging hier in dieser Umfrage eigentlich darum, was das übernächste Video sein soll
nach dem Sponsortvideo. Also das hat er anscheinend nicht so genau verstanden. Aber um zu der
anderen Geschichte mal was zu sagen. Aber übrigens Hauptsache viele Ausrufezeichen,
das ist auch immer wichtig. Und Charlatan finde ich übrigens auch so eine richtig geile
Oldschool Beleidigung. Was kommt dann als nächstes so, Max, du alter Schlawiner, du
Halunke vielleicht so geil. Da wird es jetzt aber langsam kritisch. Das ist schon fast
Monka Tostban würdig. Du Schurke, du Wicht ist auch gut. Du Gauner, du Charlatan. Falscherlern
finde ich schon gut. Haben wir genug Schabernack getrieben. Aber um dafür jetzt, ich versuche
da jetzt mal halbwegs ernsthaft drauf einzugehen, weil es ist ja schon was, was viele geschrieben
haben. Also das erste ist, dass glaube ich zumindest den vielen Leuten nicht so ganz
klar ist, wie Sponsorsachen funktionieren, sage ich mal so. Man unterschreibt da in der
Regel einen Vertrag oder trifft zumindest eine klare Abmachung, was beide Parteien machen.
Also ich mache drei Videos, ich kriege da so und so viel Geld für, da und dahin. Da
kann man dann einfach sagen, ja ne, ich mache das doch nicht. Und das geht beidseitig nicht.
Also wir haben das abgemacht. Die könnten jetzt auch nicht sagen, Max, ich bezahle
hier Statsbetrag X, jetzt betrag ich Y, einfach so, weil es ihnen danach ist. Und ich kann
auch nicht einfach sagen, ach ne, Leute, ich habe zwar unterschrieben, aber ich habe es
mir anders überlegt, ich mache jetzt das Video nicht mehr. So ist das, so funktioniert
das Ganze nicht. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das unterschrieben habe, war ja gar nicht
abzusehen, dass das Game so ein extremer reinfallen wird. Und ich meine, was soll ich jetzt machen?
Soll ich am Ende noch irgendwie Vertragsstrafe bezahlen oder was? Also das ergibt ja keinen
Sinn. Mein gut, in dem Fall wäre das mit der Vertragsstrafe wahrscheinlich nicht passiert,
weil da stand nichts drin. Aber ich glaube den Leuten ist oftmals nicht so ganz klar,
wie das Ganze läuft. Wir haben ganz klar einen Vertrag geschlossen, dass ich drei Videos
produziere und dass ich dafür X, Y kriege. Und da kann man nicht einfach, egal von welcher
Seite, sagen, ne, mach ich jetzt nicht. Und ich hab sogar vor dem Hazard Zone Video noch
an meinen Ansprechpartner geschrieben, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, das Video jetzt
zu machen. Weil das Video jetzt schon, also das letzte Video, das letzte Sponsor Video
schon nicht gut angekommen ist. Und ich hab das versucht sogar diplomatisch zu machen,
nach dem Motto, vielleicht ist es für alle Beteiligten besser, wir lassen das. Aber
als Antwort hat er mir dann geschrieben, ich soll das unbedingt draufladen. Und es läuft
ja auch oftmals über irgendwelche Agenturen, die dann auch wiederum Verpflichtungen gegenüber
EA haben. Also das ist, solche Sponsorssachen ist kein reines Wunschkonzert, wo jeder machen
kann, was er will. So und das dazu. Beim nächsten, ich hab dann einfach nur gesagt, jo, übertreib
halt, mir ist da nichts anderes eingefallen und ich fand's auch in dem Fall hier unten
etwas zu viel des Guten. Aber nachdem, es kamen ja einige Comments in dieser Richtung
und nachdem vielen auch nicht klar ist, wie soll die Sponsoring-Geschichten funktionieren,
gibt's natürlich unterschiedliche Ausprägungen von, aber in der Regel unterschreibt man da
was. Und wenn man ganz Pech hat, steht dann auch irgendeine Vertragsstrafe drin, wenn
man das nicht macht. Oder irgendwelche NDAs bricht, was dann sonst was passiert. Und jetzt
ist er, danach ist er aber komplett ausgeflippt. Danach ist er komplett ausgeflippt. Ich untertreibe
sogar noch, anstatt sich dagegen aufzulehnen, jetzt geht er richtig ab, anstatt sich dagegen
Ausrufzeichen, anstatt sich dagegen aufzulehnen, wird das Geld genommen. Das wär ja noch schöner,
das wär ja noch schöner, wenn ich Sponsort-Videos mache, weil ich vertraglich dazu verpflichtet
bin und dann auch nicht mehr das Geld nehme. Also das wär ja, wär ihm das lieber oder
was, dass ich sag, ich mach Sponsort-Video, aber ich will kein Geld dafür. Um dann später
behaupten zu können, aber ich war dagegen. Und alle anderen haben nur geschleimt, naja
gut, das war ja zum größten Teil auch so, gerade im englischsprachigen Bereich. Das
war ja nur wirklich so, kann man ja nachgucken. Mittlerweile ist die Kritik auch, muss man
sagen, aber auf allen Fronten präsent. Außer bei den Ultraschleimern, die ich am Anfang
angesprochen hab. Die sind immer noch äußerst zurückhaltend. Jetzt ohne Namen, aber ihr
kriegt's raus. Kein Wunder also, dass DICE denkt, sie hätten das beste Spiel kreiert.
Ne, dass DICE das beste Spiel kreiert hat, das liegt tatsächlich an den Schleimern,
da hat er recht. Ja, das liegt tatsächlich an den Schleimern. Das hab ich auch am Anfang
gesagt. In dem Punkt hat er natürlich recht. Das liegt natürlich nicht nur an den Schleimern.
Sie hätten das selbstverständlich feststellen können und ich denke, die meisten Leute bei
DICE war auch klar, dass dieses Spiel aktuell unfertiger ist. Aber die Schleime haben da
sicherlich eine gewisse Schuld dran. Ja, in dem Punkt würd ich ihm sogar zustimmen.
Aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht er richtig ab. Jetzt so tun, als ob du auf eine Antwort
seitens EA wartest. Na gut, das war so. Gut, das kann ich ihm nicht beweisen. Kann man
jetzt glauben, was man will. Äh, weil du ja so hart gegen das Spiel gerudert bist, hab
ich ja auch. Also, das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass EA ernsthaft happy ist über
dieses Video hier. Meinte irgendjemand, falls das jemand gesehen hat, hat sich gedacht,
oh ja, das ist ein gutes Video. Wir sind froh, dass der Max dieses Video über Battlefield
2042 hochgeladen hat. Hast du den Tweet von einem ehemaligen Battlefield-Deaf gelesen
auf Reddit? Nö. Aber kannst du mal gerne posten, können wir uns gleich angucken. Im
Leben nicht. Im Leben nicht. Die fanden das mit Sicherheit scheiße, dass ich das hochgeladen
hab. Ich bin jetzt einfach nur leid, egal von welcher Seite. Object-Frags. Ja, okay,
kann das gerne. Vesti Lost, jetzt muss er die Lost noch ein bisschen flamen. Für mich
persönlich einer der widerlichsten, klickgeilen Battlefield-Content-Creator, der Aqua, der
Siegismund, soll ich weitermachen. Okay, man merkt, er ist echt angepisst, ja. Ich kann
es verstehen, aber du solltest hauptsächlich angepisst sein, dass sie so ein kack Spiel
abgeliefert haben. Man wird immer nur angelogen und im Nachhinein heißt es dann immer, aber
ich war dagegen, blablabla, ich bin nur enttäuscht, vielleicht liegt es daran, dass ich so Denk-
und Schreiben, vielleicht. Ich bin ja auch nicht böse oder so, deshalb, aber es war
bei anderen teilweise auch so, aber ich meine, man kann sich das bei mir ganz klar angucken.
Ich hab seit der Beta, ich finde, das Comment hier geht ja teilweise schon ein bisschen
Richtung Verschwörungstheorie, so nach, alle haben das gedacht, da steckt eine klare Agenda
und sonst was dahinter. Also, man kann sich das bei meinen Videos angucken. Ich hab angefangen
mit Release der Beta. Das war der erste Eindruck, wo ich noch gedacht hab, ey, richtig geil,
das war auch nach dem Anspiel-Event, wobei ich da auch schon einige Kritikpunkte angesprochen
hab. So, nachdem ich die Beta dann 1-2 Tage gespielt habe, hab ich dieses Video hier
gemacht und ich mein, guckt euch mal diesen Titel an. Stopp, das muss DICE fixen. Die
großen Probleme vom Battlefield 2042. Sieht das irgendwie aus wie ein Video, wo DICE
gesagt hat, Max, mach das bitte. Ich glaub, auf die Idee kann keiner kommen. So, am Release-Tag
des Spiels hab ich ein Video hochgeladen, erster Eindruck hat DICE sich übernommen und
mein erster Eindruck war nicht, sondern nicht positiv, wer das Video gesehen hat. Also,
ich hab das Spiel sicherlich nicht in dem Himmel gelobt in diesem Video. So, danach
hab ich ein Sponsored-Video gemacht, hab ich noch ein Sponsored-Video gemacht, die waren
ja auch alle klar als Sponsored-Videos zu erkennen. Also, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass
irgendjemand das nicht mitbekommen hat, dass dieses Video hier zum Beispiel kein Sponsored-Video
gewesen ist. Auch bei dem hier ist direkt am Anfang die Einpim, dass es unterstützt
durch EA ist. Und danach hab ich direkt am Release-Tag, am Tag des Releases, also das
hab ich gemacht zu Early Access Start, dann hab ich zwei Sponsored-Videos gemacht, zum
Tag des Releases des Spiels hab ich dieses, am Release-Tag, man muss sich das nochmal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, so nachdem man ja immer gesagt hat, das ist das ganze
Spiel, ich hab am Release-Tag des Spiels, somit eines der härtesten Kritik-Videos über
Battlefield auf ganz YouTube hochgeladen. Das kann natürlich nur der Fall sein, dass
ich ganz klar bezahlt wurde dafür. Obvius. Anders kann das gar nicht sein. So, dann
hab ich noch ein Sponsored-Video gemacht, was auch wieder klar als Sponsored-Video zu
erkennen war und heute das Video. Also ich kann in dem Fall wirklich nicht nachvollziehen,
was sich da so drüber aufregt. Aber wie ich eingangs gesagt hab, hier, das ist tatsächlich
auch meiner Meinung nach so, hab ich ja eingangs gesagt, gerade viele große englischsprachige
Content-Creator im Battlefield-Umfeld stecken ja auch mit dem Hersteller zu sehr unter einer
Decke. Ich will nicht bestreiten, dass es es im deutschen Bereich vielleicht auch gibt,
man sollte jetzt auch nicht automatisch davon ausgehen, dass jeder, der auch nur den Hauch
eines Positiven sagt über das Spiel, automatisch gleich Geld dafür kassiert haben muss. Weil
ich wusste, wie dieses Placement aussieht und ich hab auch mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt
bei anderen Content-Creator. Ich wusste ja nach, was ich gucken muss, in der Beschreibung,
in den Texts und so was. Ich wusste sofort, was ein Sponsored-Video ist, was nicht. Und
das war alles immer als Sponsored-Video zu erkennen, wo die Sachen gelobt wurden, beziehungsweise
was gelobt wurden, wo halt die positiven Aspekte hervorgehoben wurden, die das Spiel
ja auch hat. Wahrscheinlich lässt sich da ein oder andere dort vielleicht auch zu, weil
er die Dollar-Zeichen in den Augen hat, zu Aussagen hinreißen, die vielleicht jetzt
nicht so seinem Bauchgefühl entsprechen. Aber es ist klar, als Sponsored-Video zu erkennen.
Und das ist ja das, worauf es ankommt. Ja, da hat sich eigentlich keiner, wo ich die
Videos gesehen habe, im deutschsprachigen Bereich was zu Schulden kommen lassen. Und
wie gesagt, ich hab angefangen, vom Beginn der Beta das Spiel hier zu kritisieren, war
im zweiten Video dazu. Und im ersten auch schon ein paar Punkte. Im ersten habe ich
mich, glaube ich, über Fahrzeugphysik ausgelassen, manche Sachen so leer sind. Also da kann man
sich eigentlich nicht beschweren. Und es gibt auch noch einen wichtigen Punkt, den darf
man an der Stelle nicht vergessen, wo es überhaupt nicht um Bezahlung geht, ja oder nein.
Es gibt Content-Creator, ich zum Glück nicht, aber es gibt Content-Creator, die leben davon,
Content-Creator zu sein. Der Lost zum Beispiel, weil er den ja so hart angegangen hat, der
lebt davon. Und natürlich muss ich auch der Lost zweimal überlegen, was er genau sagt.
Und vielleicht haut er nicht, und zwar nicht, weil er bei Dice schleimen will oder so,
aber vielleicht, auch wenn ihn das Game abfuckt, haut er nicht direkt zum Release ein, äh,
diese 5000 Punkte müssen an Battlefield gefixt Video werden raus, weil oftmals ist es ja
so, gerade zu Release, wenn die Leute noch nicht erkannt haben, dass das Spiel Probleme
hat, dass die Community den riesen Hate Shitstorm gegen irgendwie Creator in den Kommentaren
los tritt. Gar nicht mal. Dice macht da nix. Und gerade Leute, die davon leben, die überlegen
sich das natürlich zweimal, ob sie sowas nicht soweit aus dem Fenster lehnen und direkt
zum Release irgendwie ein ultra-kritisches Video raushauen. Dice-Geschleime hin oder
her, aber das muss nicht alles immer quasi vorauseilendes Gehorsam gegenüber des Herstellers
sein. Viele Content-Creators leben davon und oftmals kommen positive Sachen auch erst
mal besser an als negative. Das ist so. Wenn du ein sehr kritisches Video machst, kriegst
du in der Regel deutlich mehr Instant-Dislikes, als wenn du ein sehr positives Video machst.
Das soll jetzt nicht heißen, dass man die ganzen Sachen irgendwie verschweigt oder so,
aber da sollte man zumindest mal dran denken. Und zu seinen Geflame gegenüber Lost kann
ich nur aus eigener Erfahrung sagen. Übrigens Lost, falls du sie irgendwann mal sehen solltest,
du kannst gerne auf meine letzte Twitter-PN warten, falls du die gesehen hast. Wir könnten
da nämlich wirklich was zu machen. Zumindest, ich mein, ich bin mit dem Lost jetzt nicht
super dicke oder so. Wir kennen uns ne Weile, wir sind jetzt auch nicht mega Best Buddies
oder so, also wir kennen uns, würd ich sagen, sogar nur relativ flüchtig. Aber ich muss
sagen, gerade der Lost ist mit Abstand einer der nettesten Creator, die ich kennengelernt
habe in diesem elf Jahren YouTube, die ich gemacht hab. Und es ist sicherlich der letzte,
den ich irgendwie als widerlich bezeichnen würde. Das muss ich jetzt einfach mal an
der Stelle sagen. Und das nächste Comment ist ja komplett, das ist mal komplett Lost,
diese Antwort hier drauf, wo wir gerade bei ihm gewesen sind. Aber das ist mal wirklich
komplett Lost. Endlich mal einer, der es sagt, ja ok, soweit noch ok. Und nochmal, es liegt
an DICE und nicht an den Geldgeber EA. Wann raffen endlich das mal die letzte? Achja,
wo hat er denn diese Weisheit her? Das würd mich jetzt ja mal wirklich interessieren.
Wie kommt er denn zu dieser Schlussfolgerung? Und jetzt kommt übrigens auch Big Brain und
wie auch wenige wissen, an Battlefield 2042 hat ein Call of Duty Entwickler mitgewirkt.
Oh nein, da hat ein Call of Duty Entwickler mitgewirkt. Jetzt ist ja alles klar. Der Vorhang
ist gefallen, Alter. Das ist ja fast schon wie Beleg für flache Erde. Da hat ein Call
of Duty Entwickler mitgewirkt. Fuck, Alter. Ich mein, so what? Da hat ein Call of Duty
Entwickler mitgemacht. Bei der Fluktuation im Gaming Studio Jobmarkt, da ist die Fluktuation
so hoch. Wahrscheinlich haben, ob das Quelle, das kommt ja noch dazu, mit Quelle haben wir
es ja mal gar nicht so. Aber es ist auch vollkommen egal. Die Chance, dass da ein Call of Duty
Mitarbeiter mitgewirkt hat, sind sogar relativ hoch. Ich mein, die Fluktuation im Gaming
Studio Jobmarkt ist da, was Mitarbeiter angeht, ist ziemlich hoch. Und da haben wahrscheinlich
auch, wenn man mal genauer guckt, wahrscheinlich haben da auch Halo Entwickler, was weiß ich,
Mass Effect Entwickler, Assassin's Creed Entwickler oder Leute, die da mit was zu tun
haben, Minecraft Entwickler oder was weiß ich, haben da auch mitgewirkt. Es haben so
viele Leute mitgebastelt an Battlefield 2042 und die waren sicherlich schon bei so vielen
Videos vorher. Aber selbstverständlich ist da der Einhörer der Call of Duty Entwickler
dabei. Wo ist das Problem? Bestimmt auch ein SUS Entwickler. Alles. Keine Ahnung. Was genau
soll das denn jetzt belegen? Soll das jetzt irgendwie ein Indiz dafür sein, dass Battlefield
2042 ein Call of Duty Klon ist? Also man kann ja von Battlefield 2042 halten, was man will.
Und es hat offensichtliche Call of Duty Warzone Einflüsse. Aber das jetzt einen Call of Duty
Klon zu nennen. Also ich mein, allein schon, wie unfertig kacke das Game gerade ist. Ich
mein, man kann sich über Call of Duty aufregen, wie man will, aber Vanguard ist in einem Zustand,
das läuft wenigstens. Also da hat es ja wohl auch nicht, also die Qualität hat er da wohl
auch nicht reingebracht. Ne. Und das Dice irgendwie das Problem wäre auch nicht. Ich
glaube, das ist wie bei vielem, es gibt nicht das Problem, was du hundertprozentig einem
zuschustern kannst. Ich denke mal, Dice hat mit Scheiße gebaut, allerdings auch EA. Und
wenn ich auf einen zeigen müsste, so jetzt rein Bauchgefühl, natürlich kenne ich da
mich mit internen Abläufen nicht aus. Aber wenn ich jetzt auf einen zeigen müsste, der
da maßgeblich mit dazu beigetragen hat, dass dieses Spiel in diesem unfertigen Zustand
rauskommt, dann ist es EA. Ich mein, Dice wird doch nicht von sich aus gesagt haben,
ach ja, wir sind richtig scharf drauf, so ein unfertiges Game zu veröffentlichen. Warum
sollten die das sagen? Das wäre ja komplett hirnverbrannt. Da wird schon irgendjemand
von EA oben gesagt haben, so nach dem Motto, okay, wir geben euch jetzt noch die zwei Monate,
aber diesen Weihnachten muss das raus. Und wenn Dice dann sagt, wie sieht es mit nächsten
Weihnachten aus, dann machen die einfach nur, wenn du es nicht hinkriegst, macht halt jemand
anderes deinen Job. Aber im Zweifelsfall den Call of Duty Entwickler schuld, ja. Also
richtig, richtiger Blödsinn. Das sagt uns mal genau nix. Alter, meine Güte. Ja, es
gab noch mehr komische Comments, ja. Zum Beispiel, einer hat geschrieben, das fand ich auch witzig,
einer hat geschrieben, 128 Spieler finde ich richtig gut, das erhöht den Skill, den man
braucht und man muss einfach nur die Reactions haben, um mit 128 Spielern umzugehen. Und was
ich dann witzig finde, ich habe mir mal ein paar Ausschnitte angeguckt, wo, ich glaube,
es war Shroud, wo Shroud Battlefield 2042 spielt. Also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
wir jetzt Shroud unterstellen wollen, er hat nicht die Reactions. Und er hatte exakt
die gleichen Probleme. Weiß nicht, ob man das alles so auf die Reactions schieben kann.
Na ja. Dann gab's Leute, die haben geschrieben, das kann ich jetzt nicht alles raussuchen,
das sind ja 1700 Comments, dann gab's Leute, die sindgemäß sowas geschrieben haben wie
Max, was laberst du da für nen Scheiß, mit der Kern des Spiels ist schlecht, was meinst
du denn mit Kern? Da weiß ich nicht, wie ich den Leuten erklären soll, was ich mit Kern
meine. Es fällt mir unglaublich schwierig, jetzt aus dem Stegreif das Wort Kern zu definieren.
Ich könnte jetzt die mega Big Brain High IQ Zitat bringen, wir zitieren jetzt einfach
mal Goethe. Faust Teil 1. Jetzt wird's richtig massiv. Der Kern ist, ich kenne, ob ich dieses
Zitat richtig zusammenkriege, irgendwann sagt er sowas wie, dass ich erkenne, was die Welt
im Innersten zusammenhält. Das ist der Kern. Der Kern des Games. So quasi die innersten
Mechanics, die einander greifen müssen. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Kern erklären soll.
Aber jetzt haben wir wenigstens auch mal Faust zitiert. Massiv. Der Chat IQ ist als erstes
mal 20 Punkte durch die Decke gegangen. Ja, dass sie die alten Fans gemolken haben, nämlich
ihnen immer noch übel, von wegen Basejump gezeigt, Rakete mit aus dem Chat gezeigt,
dann haben sie so Dinge als irgendwie Liebeserklärung an die Community und sowas. Das nimm ich
ihnen wirklich übel, dass die alten Fans gemolken werden. Letztendlich darf man nicht vergessen,
wir sind als Spieler bei vielen gerade im Management quasi notwendiges Übel, um Geld
zu verdienen. Ich glaube, so kann man das sagen. Und manche haben jetzt ja auch den
Untergang von Battlefield Prophezeit, das habe ich ja auch so ein bisschen angesprochen
in meinem Video so nach dem Motto, ich weiß nicht, ob die nicht Battlefield bis zu einem
gewissen Maß vernichtet haben mit diesem Release. Und ja, das glaube ich immer noch, aber in
der heutigen Zeit wird immer was rebooted. Das wird garantiert nicht das letzte Battlefield
sein, was wir gesehen haben. Und vielleicht musste es nach dem Reinfall, nicht ganz so
großen Reinfall, aber auch Reinfall mit Battlefield 5 und dem wahnsinnig verkackten Marketing
drum herum. Und jetzt diesem verkackten Launch und dem halbherzigen Battlefield 2042, wo
wir gerade dabei sind, wir gucken mal kurz Steam, Steam Stats. Ich meine, die meisten
werden über Origin spielen, aber wir gucken ja nicht Open Beta. Wir gucken, wir gucken
trotzdem mal. Sieben Tage. Na, ist schon, ist schon einiges runtergegangen. Jetzt haben
schon viele keinen Bock mehr drauf. Eigentlich hätte ich erwartet, dass das noch ein bisschen
steigt jetzt am Anfang. Aber nee, das ist instant gejobbt. Kann man aber auch verstehen
bei dem Game. Und vielleicht muss erst Battlefield so, wie es jetzt ist, auch in den Köpfen
von Stonks Managern bei EA, vielleicht muss einfach Battlefield zu Grabe getragen werden,
dass man irgendwann vielleicht mal was Gutes Neues bekommt, dass man kreativen Leuten
ein bisschen mehr freie Hand lässt, mehr Freiräume lässt und nicht so sehr reinredet, was sowas
angeht. Vielleicht ist das, vielleicht ist Battlefield 2042 eventuell das notwendige
Übel, was wir gebraucht haben, dass wir irgendwann mal wieder ein gutes Battlefield kriegen.
Man weiß es nicht. Keiner viel darüber philosophieren, wenn der Tag lang ist. Wir gucken mal Halo
Infinite Steam Stats. Die dürften wahrscheinlich ähnlich sein. Leute, spielen mehr Leute Halo
auf dem PC konstanter als Battlefield. Und das Spiel ist nicht mehr raus. Allerdings
ist natürlich dieser Vergleich hinkt, weil sehr viele Leute über Origin spielen. Das
darf man nicht vergessen. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass wahrscheinlich zwei Drittel
von Battlefield über Origin spielen. Das sind ungefähr die gleichen Spielzahlen. Leute,
ich muss jetzt gleich schon spät. Sorry, dass ich so lange jetzt mit dem YouTube Zeug
rumgelabert habe, aber ich musste das einfach mal loswerden. Eigentlich wollte ich mir heute
hier richtig, richtig neiße Deals noch angucken. Zum Glück habt ihr abgestimmt, dass wir uns
wenigstens ein paar Sachen angeguckt haben am Anfang. Aber wir werden auf jeden Fall
den Stream fortsetzen, spätestens am Freitag, wo es dann hoffentlich die richtig guten Deals
gibt, falls überhaupt zu was dabei sein wird. Aber das muss ich mal sagen. Zieh dir den
Tweet noch rein, mach ich. Wo denn? Okay. Okay. If this doesn't explain the current state
of DICE right now, I don't know what does. Good. Johann Gerell. When I was at DICE and
complained in, okay, also er war mal DICE und hat gemeckert. Allerdings, wie soll man
sagen? Also nicht geflamed, sondern noch mit dem nötigen Anstand. In internen Chats über,
oh, jetzt geht's hier über offensichtlich bescheuerte Designentscheidungen, hauptsächlich
Battlefield 1 Dom. Ist das eine Map? Oder ist das Domination oder was ist damit gemeint?
Bf1 Dom. Hat irgendjemand einen Plan? Oder ist Dom jemand von DICE? Na gut. So und hat
gefragt, er hat gefragt, ob die Designer überhaupt das Spiel spielen. Ja, Domination, ja. Also
ob die Designer überhaupt das Spiel spielen. Er hat, ihm wurde schnell klar gemacht, dass
er die Klappe halten soll. Soll. Mit bescheuerten Argumenten sogar vom Lead Designer. Oh Gott,
wirklich? Ernsthaft? Okay, die Begründung war, die Begründung, warum er die Klappe
halten soll, war er soll er soll daran denken, wenn er sowas schreibt, dass der Designer
dieses Features ja auch in diesem Chat sein könnte und er sich dadurch gekränkt fühlen
würde. Seriously? Ich mein, wenn man in einem internen Chat zu einem Game noch nicht mal
schreiben kann, dass man, ich mein, wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt krass rumflennt, alter ihr
kackspasten, ihr habt ja sowas gemacht, das verstehe ich ja, das sollte man auch nicht
machen, das ist auch der Arbeitsatmosphäre sicherlich nicht zuträglich. Aber das ist
dann doch etwas übertrieben. Ich mein, wenn du in einem internen Chat nicht über das
Game diskutieren kannst, wo du gerade am entwickeln bist und wenn du aus, wenn Bedenken
über dieses Game nicht geäußert werden können, dann heißt, man kann intern auch keine Iterationen
machen, um zu gucken, was funktioniert und was kann man verbessern. Weil, wenn man es
nicht ansprechen kann, dann wird das ja nichts. Natürlich kennen wir die andere Seite nicht,
vielleicht hätte es durchaus irgendwelche Feedback-Sachen gegeben, wo man das Ganze hätte
ansprechen können. Man muss auch sagen, dass die Frage an sich nicht sonderlich nett
formuliert ist. Ich mein, das bedeutet ja im Endeffekt, schön, also diese Frage, so
wie er das stellt, könnte man schon ein bisschen passiv-aggressiv in die Richtung deuten, habt
ihr eigentlich einen Plan, was ihr da überhaupt macht. Aber Fragen in dieser Art, auch wenn
das sicherlich keine, wie soll ich sagen, netten Fragen sind und nichts, wo sich einer
jetzt freut, das zu lesen, sollten gerade intern Fragen in dieser Richtung schon gestellt
werden können. Weil vielleicht macht man ja wirklich sehr bescheuerte Dinge. Ja. Das
ist natürlich nicht sinnvoll. Man muss da, denke ich, immer eine gute Balance finden zwischen
gute Arbeitsatmosphäre und kritisieren. Also, man darf es halt nicht einseitig komplett
übertreiben. Also, es hat auch keinen Sinn, wenn so krass alles kritisiert wird und schlecht
geredet, nicht kritisiert, schlecht geredet wird, sodass sich am Ende wiederum keiner
traut, was zu sagen. Das ist natürlich beides nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Also, man
muss da schon eine gute Balance finden. Aber gerade, wenn man zusammen im Team an einem
Produkt arbeitet, dann muss man ja verschiedene Sachen durchprobieren. Und auch ausprobieren,
feststellen, klappt nicht und wieder wegschmeißen. Man sollte nicht jede Kritik quasi gleich
persönlich nehmen. Das ist auch etwas, wo ich mich persönlich am Anfang wirklich schwer
getan habe, als ich angefangen habe zu arbeiten. Da kann ich mich dran erinnern. Ich habe alles,
was jemand gesagt hat, ich habe etwas gemacht und irgendjemand fand das nicht gut, dann
habe ich das immer gleich persönlich genommen. Da habe ich gerade, oh, der mag das nicht,
irgendwie weil ich das gemacht habe oder so. Das ist aber nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Solange sich das gegen die Sache richtet und nicht gegen den, der sich das ausgedacht
hat, dann ist es okay. Deswegen finde ich das, so wie er das gefragt hat, vielleicht
auch ein bisschen unglücklich. Aber trotzdem, du musst über Probleme, die es gibt, diskutieren
können, gerade wenn du ein gutes Produkt abliefern willst. Und dann macht es keinen
Sinn, wenn man quasi alles, was man sagt, vorher erst mal drei Tage durchdenken muss,
wenn man es sagt, in der Hoffnung, dass man es dann irgendwie so in Watte verpackt hat,
dass alle zufrieden sind. Da kommt ja nichts bei rum. Da brauchst du ja für alles drei
Monate. Vor allem als Entwickler und Designer, ja.
Ich denke, dass da ein gesundes Mittelmaß echt der beste Weg ist. Und oftmals, auch
wenn ich kein Fan dieser Sache bin, aber in dem Fall triff es tatsächlich, oftmals ist
gesunder Menschenverstand oder, soll man sagen, Menschenkenntnis vielleicht oder Bauchgefühl,
kann das nennen, wie man will. In solchen Fällen vielleicht sogar der beste Ratgeber,
ob man jemand was so sagen kann oder nicht. Ja, wenn ich jetzt weiß zum Beispiel, dass
einer super zart beseitigt ist, wie gesagt, ich habe euch ja schon mal die Story erzählt,
wo ich den Azubi nach Netzwerktechnik gefragt hat, und er hat dann angefangen, einen halben
Nervenzusammenbruch zu kriegen, das war überhaupt nicht meine Absicht. Ich meine, wer kann
damit rechnen, dass wenn du den Azubi nach Netzwerktechnik fragst, der auf einmal einen
halben Nervenzusammenbruch hat? Zumal wir eine Woche lang geübt haben zusammen und er meinte
dann einfach zu mir, als ich ihn gefragt habe, so nach dem Motto, jetzt nicht, Max, lass mich
in Ruhe oder so, singelmäßig. Da habe ich halt gemeint, ne, jetzt nicht, wir haben das
eine Woche geübt, außerdem brauchst du das für die Prüfung, jetzt erzähl halt mal.
So, und da hat er einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch gekriegt. So, das wusste ich nicht, jetzt,
nachdem ich das wusste, oder nachdem mir das klar ist, wäre ich bei dem natürlich dann
besonders vorsichtig gewesen. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die hauen dann richtig rein, das ist
nicht das, was ich jetzt befürworten würde, wenn man das weiß, man sollte da schon Rücksicht
drauf nehmen. Ich hätte sowas in dieser energischen Art dann nicht mehr gemacht, aber in dem Moment
hat es mich natürlich auch aufgeregt. Wir haben eine Woche geübt und er sagt einfach
ne, jetzt nicht. Also was ist das für eine Antwort, ja. Also es ist echt so ein Thema
unserer Zeit, dass man alles irgendwie, jegliche Art von Kritik gleich als Hass, Hate und sonst
was auffasst. Das ist gut, ja. Das stimmt. Na gut, Leute, wir kommen uns spätestens am
Freitag noch mehr Angebote an. Ich war heute, ich hab mich etwas zu mehr, etwas zu viel,
ich muss, da muss ich jetzt auch was dran sagen. Ich finde, das ist auch immer zu hart. Es
gibt genug gescheite Leute, gerade auf Twitter, wohlgemerkt auf Twitter. Twitter ist ja nun
wohl die Hate-Flame-Plattform schlechthin, was abweichende Meinungen angeht, aber auch
gerade in der jüngeren Generation habe ich genug Aussagen gesehen, lustigerweise sogar
aus dem Call of Duty Content Creator Sektor, wo man sich darüber aufgeregt hat, dass die
Generation teilweise viel zu überempfindlich ist und sie gehören selbst zu dieser Generation.
Da kann man auch nicht alle über einen Kamm scheren und ich finde es auch nicht gut zu
sagen, so nach dem Motto Alter, die Leute können gar nichts ab, deswegen muss man da
jetzt besonders draufhauen, das nicht. Aber es kann natürlich auch im Umkehrschluss nicht
sein, dass man vor alles und jedem immer drei Wochen überlegen muss, dass man auch ja gar
nichts Falsches sagt, weil dann dauert alles einfach ewig. Ich finde immer noch Twitter
ist das beste Social-Network. Aber auf Twitter ist wirklich Müll. Aber ich sage, das ist
auch nicht bei allen so. Du hast halt heute viele, die sind so berufsmäßig, man könnte
fast denken, es ist ihr Job empfindlich zu sein. Die sind empfindlich über alles, egal
was gesagt wird, sie sind empfindlich und offended. Also Twitter ist das beste Beispiel
für das, egal aus welchem Themensspektrum oder aus welchem Gesinnensspektrum, wie auch
immer, dass die Leute einfach nur empört sind. Über alles. Egal was. Wenn ich auf
Twitter schreiben würde, meine Lieblingsfarbe ist blau, da werden auch Leute empört. Auf
Twitter ist man über alles empört. Das ist tatsächlich auch wirklich ein Punkt. Heutzutage
kann man seine Gedanken auf Social-Media-Kund tun. Früher hat man sich auch aufgeregt.
Ich weiß noch, wie sehr der Opa beispielsweise geflamet hat über Leute auf seine Arbeit
und sowas. Nur hat es da außerdem im Umkreis keinen großartig interessiert. Heute ist es
allerdings so, ich finde, das Posten auf Social-Media ist gar nicht das Ding. Das Zusammenrotten
zu solchen Flame-Kreisen auf Social-Media, das ist das eigentliche Problem. Weil die
Leute halten sich quasi nur noch in ihrer eigenen Plase auf, wo sie quasi immer nur
die Bestätigung bekommen, ja unsere Weltanschauung ist richtig, unsere Weltanschauung ist die
einzig richtige. Jeder, der was anderes sagt, ist scheiße. So und wenn man das mal 2-3 Jahre
gemacht hat, dann bist du wirklich bis in den Kern, wo wir es vorhin davon hatten, überzeugt
davon, dass das so ist. Und du lässt auch keinerlei andere abweichendere Meinung zu.
Und du bist dann mittlerweile, ich meine Twitter ist das beste Beispiel, die sind super schnell
dabei. Abweichende Meinung, das ist dann entweder ein Nazi, ein versiffter Gutmensch, ein Verschwörungstheoretiker,
ein Impfleugner, ein Corona, was auch immer, Verschwörungs-Typ. Es ist immer, also sobald
du dich nicht in der jeweiligen Blase mehr aufhältst oder irgend einer was dagegen sagt,
dann sind die Leute, die am lautesten schreien, so nach dem Motto Toleranz, Toleranz, meistens
die intolerantesten, die es so gibt. Also auf Twitter, auf Twitter. Twitter ist da ganz
besonders abartig. Also das ist wirklich schlimm. Also Twitter ist wirklich echt komplett Cancer,
was das angeht. Deswegen gibt's da auch überhaupt nichts. Deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht, warum
so viele Leute auf Twitter Shitstorms reagieren. Twitter Shitstorm, was weiß ich, Sendung
wird von YouTube gelöscht oder aus der Mediathek genommen. Twitter Shitstorm, irgendwelche
Leute posten öffentliche Entschuldigungen. Warum? Scheiß, Scheiß auf Twitter Empörung.
Twitter Empörung sehe ich und die geilen, die geilen sind nicht immer ganz zurechnungsfähigen,
außer ich natürlich. Da würde ich überhaupt nichts drauf geben, wenn sich, wenn sich
Twitter aufregt. Das kannst du mal getrost vergessen. Ich bin auf Andorra. Ich bin auf
Andorra. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Du meinst diese Geschichte mit Toleranz gegenüber Intoleranten.
Da gebe ich dir Recht. Das ist tatsächlich ein interessantes Thema. Aber ich glaube,
bei den meisten Fällen trifft das gar nicht zu. Bei den meisten auf Twitter geht es darum,
alles, was nicht der eigenen Meinung entspricht, ist automatisch Trash. Aber sie denken von
sich. Sie wären die Tolerantesten auf der Welt. Das ist ja anders gelagert. Nee, aber
Twitter ist wirklich nicht normal. Und eins noch dazu. Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn irgendwelche
Twitter Bubbles anfangen, rumzuhaten. Es hat dann auch keinen Sinn, wenn die Leute danach
hingehen und erst mal überrascht sind. So nach dem Motto, hoch, hier werde ich ja auf
einmal richtig krass gehatet. Und danach werden irgendwelche Entschuldigungen gepostet. Du
kannst es komplett vergessen, gegen eine aufgebrachte Twitter Blase, die gerade am Shitstorm ist,
dich zu entschuldigen. Weil höchstwahrscheinlich, so bei diesen Larifari-Dingern, weil irgendwie
sich einer in einer Fernsehsendung versprochen hat oder so, was da immer für ein Fass aufgemacht
wird auf Twitter. Erstens gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu entschuldigen, weil einfach
gar nichts passiert ist, außer normal denkenden Gründen. Aber sich zu entschuldigen führt
ja nicht mal dazu, dass die Twitter-Leute dich weniger haten. Die haten dich danach
noch mehr, weil sie sagen, ah ja, guck mal da, wenn er sich schon entschuldigen muss,
dann war es erst recht ernst gemeint. Also ich glaube noch keine Entschuldigung versus
den Twitter-Mob hat irgendwie dazu geführt, dass der Shitstorm weniger geworden ist. Außerdem
gestehen sich die Leute dann quasi ein, dass sie eventuell sogar was falsch gemacht haben,
weil das hätten sie sich ja nicht entschuldigen müssen. Also Twitter ist am besten einfach
man ignoriert es, wenn da geshitstormt wird. Ich glaube das wäre für alle Beteiligten
auch das beste. Das stimmt, manchmal ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht schlecht. Gerade
mal angenommen, man ist wirklich, vielleicht nicht YouTube-weg, sondern gerade auch Leute,
die irgendwelche Sachen im Fernsehen moderieren oder sonst was, die kriegen ja regelmäßig
aktuell irgendwelche Shitstorms ab, weil von allen möglichen, weil die falsche Farbe
erwähnt ist, weil irgendwas nicht richtig repräsentiert ist, weil man das falsche Wort
für irgendwas verwendet hat. Und wenn man sich die Fälle anguckt, sind die oftmals wirklich
belanglos. Ja ich shitstorme gerade gegen Twitter, also gegen Twitter Shitstormer shitstorme
ich. Das meiste ist wirklich belanglos. Gibt durchaus auch mal ein paar harte Dinger, wo
ich mir denke, oh das war jetzt nicht so gut das zu sagen. Habt ihr meine Video-Meme-Channel
verlinkt? Naja, was soll ich sagen. Wir machen am Freitag weiter mit, mit ähm, ups.
Ähm, wir machen am Freitag weiter mit Angebote. Oh das will ich jetzt hier nicht, nicht ansprechen,
ich glaube dann bin ich noch eine halbe Stunde unterwegs. Wobei, ich, ich kann ja mal kurz
was zu sagen. Ich hab meine Meinung dazu tatsächlich geändert. Ich hab meine Meinung dazu ein bisschen,
ein bisschen geändert. Ich war ja ursprünglich komplett gegen, also so Eingriffe in, dass
du das komplett selbst bestimmen kannst. Also hättest du mich vor einem Jahr oder einem
halben Jahr noch gefragt, hätt ich gesagt, nein ich will das auf gar keinen Fall. Mittlerweile
muss ich sagen, hat sich das ein bisschen aufgeweicht. Ich bin immer noch kein Fan davon,
dass man das Leuten vorschreiben muss. Aber ich glaube, dass wir anerweitig nicht mehr
auf den grünen Zweig kommen. An sich finde ich es scheiße, weil sowas rein auf freiwilliger
Basis sein sollte. Und man frei entscheiden können sollte, ob man das macht oder nicht.
Aber ich fürchte, wir kommen auf keinen grünen Zweig mehr ohne. Das heißt, ich bin da so
ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Ich finde es an sich vom Ansatz her massiv scheiße,
dass sowas verpflichtend gemacht wird. Auf der anderen Seite wüsste ich auch nicht,
was man sonst machen soll. Das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Grandmaster
Zeit, danke für den Sub. Äh, ich denke schon, weil am Freitag ist ja dann offiziell Black
Friday. Bin aber gleich weg. Ja, die Bill Gates, was die immer mit Bill Gates haben
verstehe ich auch nicht. Na gut, ich finde, das zählt wiederum nicht als Argument. Nur
weil man irgendwann mal irgendwas gemacht hat, heißt es nicht automatisch, dass das
jetzt angemessen ist für das Aktuelle. Wir haben sicherlich schon mal in der Vergangenheit
viel Blödsinn gemacht, egal was du da nimmst. Ja, die Franzosen waren auch mal der Meinung,
es ist eine gute Idee, dass man Leute köpfen soll. Das heißt, es ist trotzdem auch in
heutigen Zeit dann vielleicht keine gute Idee, Leute zu köpfen. Nur weil man mal was gemacht
hat, ist es vielleicht nicht automatisch sinnvoll, das wiederzumachen. Ja gut, das zeigt, dass
die Strategie funktioniert. Ja, so könnte man das sehen. Die Strategie hat damals ja
funktioniert. Also ich glaube pauschal kann man das kann man das nicht sagen. Man muss
das im Einzelfall abwägen, ob das verhältnismäßig ist und angemessen ist. Es ist auch egal,
ich weiß, dass es auch was für Masern gibt. Man muss sich wirklich den Fall angucken,
ob das quasi das Einschränken der Freiheit, das einen das für die Gesamtheit aufwiegt.
Ja, dass das, wenn man es denn macht, erfolgreich ist. Ich glaube, das steht außer Zweifel.
Aber man kann nicht immer gleich den Hammer auspacken. Aber ich glaube auch, dass es
mittlerweile nicht mehr anders geht. Das sehe ich anders. Ich bin kein Fan davon, von den
Leuten vor sich selbst beschützen. Problematisch wird es nur in so einem Fall, wo es dann auch
andere betrifft. Okay, deswegen sage ich ja auch, ich habe da meine Meinung in letzter
Zeit zu geändert. Aber prinzipiell, wenn einer Scheiße machen will, sollte ihm freigestellt
sein, Scheiße zu machen. Zuerst mal ganz prinzipiell. In dem Fall ist es natürlich
ein bisschen anders gelagert. Aber wenn einer jetzt aus dem Flugzeug springen will, ohne
Fallschirm, dann kann er das machen. Wenn er Spaß dran hat. Einmalig, meinetwegen. Aber
nachdem das hier andere betrifft, sieht es natürlich anders aus. Ey, das ist auch so
ein Ding, ne? Sie haben jetzt ja irgendwie, habe ich letztes Mal gelesen, dass die Leute
im Darknet die Impfzertifikate verkauft haben. Genau, genau, das meine ich ja. Also die Leute
haben quasi im Darknet Impfzertifikate verkauft und haben jetzt die Daten oder drohen jetzt
oder haben jetzt, weiß ich, die persönlichen Daten der Leute, die sie gekauft haben, wiederum
verkauft. Da siehst du mal, denen geht es im Prinzip auch nur um Stonks. Die wollen
einfach nur Geld machen, denen ist es scheißegal. Ja gut, laut Verschwörungstelekramsachen
ist die Welt doch auch schon untergegangen, beziehungsweise sind doch schon irgendwie
Millionen gestorben an Corona, oder? Haben die das nicht prophezeit für im April werden
Millionen sterben oder sowas? Es ist ja nicht passiert. Was wollte eigentlich ein Praktikum
im Garten, Landschaftswahl machen? Ach so, so ein internes Praktikum oder so. Ja gut,
das ist Fils Batman. Auf der anderen Seite könntest du argumentieren, hey, da bin ich
doch draußen. Wenn ich im Freien bin, ist doch noch viel besser für Corona.
Genau solche Überschriften gab es dann da. Es gibt ernsthaft dazu Überlegungen,
ob wir nicht in einer Simulation leben. Gibt es coole YouTube-Videos, so habe ich schon
ein paar geguckt, es abgedrehte Sachen und haben sich auch schon wirklich seriöse Leute
mit beschäftigt, ob wir nicht in der Matrix sind. Übrigens, ich weiß, gleich ist schon
spät, schon spät, Bettge. Ich finde aber eine Sache, jetzt noch mal zu dieser Corona-Geschichte,
ich denke viele der Leute, die jetzt sich nicht impfen lassen wollen, da liegt das
nicht daran, dass die irgendwie nicht richtig informiert sind oder sonst was. Das habe ich
ja auch lange Zeit gesagt, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht der Fall. Ich denke, 90% von
denen, die sich jetzt nicht impfen lassen, da hat das andere Gründe. Die machen das aus
Prinzip. Warum auch immer, welches Prinzip das sein mag. Welche, die sagen, ich mag
den Druck von außen nicht, was auch immer. Kann ja alles Mögliche sein. Jetzt habe ich
vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Lull. Ja, keine Ahnung. Battlefield wird noch nicht gespielt.
Jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Schon spät. Ach ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder,
was ich sagen wollte. Genau. Also ich denke schon. Alter, Lull. Richtig, richtig boomer
hier gerade. Wo war ich denn jetzt gerade? Ach ja, okay, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Lull, jetzt weiß ich wieder. Also ich denke schon, dass das bei den meisten, die sich
jetzt nicht impfen lassen wollen, andere Gründe hat. Aus irgendwelchen. Die wollen halt aus
irgendwelchen Gründen. Die mögen nicht beeinflusst werden von außen. Die mögen es nicht, dass
man ihnen sagt, dass sie das machen sollen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es an Mangel der
Information liegt. Aber man muss sich aber auch mal eingestehen bei der Gelegenheit,
dass wir sicherlich und ich sage jetzt halt mal wir, ich meine damit aber hauptsächlich
auch politische Entscheidung, dass wir da schon auch dazu beigetragen haben bei dem
ein oder anderen, dass es soweit gekommen ist. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass nicht
von Anfang an viele Leute so komplett dagegen waren. Aber wir haben da auch mit zu beigetragen.
Es gab ja einige komische Entscheidungen. Es gab das hin und her mit dieser AstraZeneca
Geschichte. Erst nur Junge, dann keine Junge mehr, dann ausgesetzt, dann keine Alten, dann
wieder nur Alte und so. Das war alles bestimmt begründet, aber schlecht kommuniziert. Das
war schlecht kommuniziert. Genau Informationspolitik. Das war schlecht kommuniziert. Ja, dann hatten
wir irgendwelche willkürlich gesetzten Grenzen ab wie viel Quadratmeter man was darf und
sonst was. Da hatte man schon den Eindruck, so wirklich Plan dahinter ist nicht. Und man
muss ja auch mal sagen, man kann ja durchaus geimpft sein und auch Corona für schlimm
halten, aber trotzdem Maßnahmen, die getroffen werden, kritisieren. Man sollte nicht alle
Leute, die sagen, sie finden es nicht gut, wie X, Y gehandelt wurde, wie mit X, Y umgegangen
wurde gleich sagen, aha, hier Corona-Leugner, Impfgegner. Also da gibt es ja schon ein breites
Spektrum. Ich finde auch nicht, nämlich auch nicht, dass alles gut gelaufen ist, was wir
da gemacht haben. Und auch solche Geschichten wie diese Aufenthaltsdaten, so was man in
Restaurants eintragen musste. Ich war keine Ahnung, ich war Burger futtern um 14.30 bis
15 Uhr mit den anwesenden Personen. Da hat man auch am Anfang ganz klar gesagt, hey,
das verwenden wir, vielleicht stand es auch in irgendeinem Kleingedruckten anders, aber
man hat es auf jeden Fall so kommuniziert. Das verwenden wir auch nur zum Nachverfolgen
der Infektionsketten. Paar Wochen später kam die bayerische Polizei, ah ja, easy, wir haben
jetzt auch Zugriff drauf, verwenden das auch. Also so schaffst du da ja auch nicht wirklich
Vertrauen drin. Und mit solchen und ähnlichen Dingern haben wir sicherlich es mit der Informationspolitik
und mit der Kommunikation verkackt oder wurde es verkackt. Und das hat bestimmt dazu geführt,
dass die ein oder anderen Leute noch negativer eingestellt sind jetzt, als sie am Anfang
waren gegen diese ganze Impfgeschichte. Ein aktuelles Beispiel, aktuelles Beispiel ist
ja auch diese ganze Sache um Rationierung mit dieser BioNTech Geschichte. Ich kann es nicht
ganz nachvollziehen, warum man nicht einfach die Sachen kauft. Ich weiß, hat jemand verfolgt,
warum das nicht geht? Gibt es das nicht oder was? Ich meine, man hat wohl irgendwelche
Impfdosen, die sonst verfallen. Aber um was geht es denn jetzt? Geht es jetzt darum, dass
sich möglichst viele Leute impfen lassen oder dass wir ein bisschen Geld sparen? Also wichtig
in dem Fall ist doch, dass anscheinend, ob das jetzt wissenschaftlich fundiert ist oder
nicht, ist doch scheißegal. Dass viele Leute eben diesem BioNTech Impfstoff anscheinend
trauen. So, ob das sinnvoll ist, das zu bevorzugen versus dem anderen, ob das irgendwie begründet
ist oder nicht, ist doch eigentlich über vollkommen egal. Wenn wir wissen, dass die
Leute dem mehr trauen als dem anderen, dann sollten wir den kaufen. Ja, solche Aussagen
sind auch nicht förderlich. Aber wenn es doch klar ist, dass die Leute sich quasi lieber
impfen lassen damit als damit, dann sollte man es doch einfach kaufen. Also wenn unser
Ziel ist, dass sich möglichst viele impfen lassen. Da verstehe ich den Hickack drumherum
jetzt nicht wirklich. Ja, das mag sein. Aber trotzdem ist eine Impfung immer noch besser
als keine Impfung. Und wenn du mit zweimal damit mehr Leute zum Doktor kriegst, die sich
eine Spritze geben lassen, als in der Kombination, dann sollte man dafür sorgen, dass das möglich
ist. Umso weniger Leute man dazu zwingen muss mit irgendwelchen Maßnahmen, umso besser.
Ich frage mich eh, wie sie das umsetzen wollen. Ganz ehrlich, wenn man sagt, ich meine, Impfpflicht
kann ja verschiedene Stufen haben. Natürlich fängt es erstmal an mit Nachteilen für Ungeimpfte.
Das kann aber gehen bis zu, jetzt nennen wir mal die China-Variante, so nach dem Motto,
die Polizei kommt heim und drückt ihr das Ding rein. Das haben wir natürlich nicht,
aber was ich sagen will, es gibt da verschiedene Ausbaustufen. Ich frage mich eh, was sie machen
wollen, wenn viele Leute weiterhin sagen, nein, wir weigern uns. Da bin ich wirklich
mal gespannt. Da bin ich echt gespannt, was dann passiert. Und ich garantiere euch, es
gibt genug, die sich weigern werden. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was wir machen. Na,
weil wir es gerade von der französischen Variante hatten vorhin, nur weil mal was gut
funktioniert hat, heißt es nicht unbedingt, dass wir die immer noch anwenden sollten.
Genau, die Sache ist aber die, was machst du, wenn die Leute ihrer Pflicht nicht nachkommen.
Und da bin ich wirklich gespannt. Da bin ich echt gespannt, was da kommt. Das Spahn
erzählt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist. Und ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen, was
wir gerade vom Spahn hatten, ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass laut YouTube-Comment,
dass laut YouTube-Comment, ich quasi ähnlich schlimm bin, wie der Spahn. Möchte ich jetzt
noch mal kurz darauf hinweisen, ja. Guckt es euch an. Wisst, jetzt finde ich es nicht
mehr hier. Die BlaBla-Videos sind genau so viel, wie der Herr Spahn seinen Mund aufmacht.
So, so. Spahn-FPS. Oh Mann. Gut, Leute, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett. Wir gucken uns am Freitag,
gucken wir uns das an. Was ist dann für Black Friday-Deals gibt es, ob es wirklich was
Gutes gibt diesmal. Ich habe mich heute etwas lange abreagiert an der ganzen YouTube-Geschichte.
Aber trotzdem, schön, wenn es euch gefallen hat. Die ursprüngliche Geschichte haben wir
leider nur eine halbe Stunde durchgezogen. Dann musste ich mich über YouTube-Geschichten
auskotzen. Also, war es gut. Ich gucke mal schnell, ob schon irgendjemand... Warum kann
ich denn niemanden... Hä? Die Anzeige funktioniert bei mir nicht mit Leuten, denen ich follow.
Was ist denn hier los? Sack. Warum funktioniert meine Follow-Anzeige nicht? Oh, auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm. Keine Ahnung. Bug seit einer Woche, alles klar. Na gut, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Was ist denn? Was? Wie wäre es denn? Das ist eine gute Idee. Nein, wir starten keinen
Battlefield-3-Server, aber wir spielen mal eine Runde Battlefield-3 demnächst. Das finde
ich eine super Idee. Und ich hoffe, dass wenn ich mich zu so aktuellen Themen auslasse,
man mir folgen kann, zumindest verstehen kann, was ich sagen will. Ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl, Boomer hierin macht es nicht mehr so ganz mit, sinnvolle Sätze zu bilden. Also,
macht's gut, bis denn, see you.